so let's start with this purpose is not
passion they're related but they're not
the same thing passion is also not that
hard to figure out neither is purpose
people just have not been given the
right tools so let's simplify it for you
today and if you're someone who's
struggling to figure out what your
purpose and your passion are this video
is going to be insanely helpful for you
I have a who why how process who is your
most important core value we're not
going to dive into that in this video
but the next two are your why and your
how your why is your purpose and your
how is your passion so let's start with
purpose your purpose is your why your
purpose comes from your pain your
purpose is whatever the thing you
struggled with the most in life think
back to the most painful moment in your
life what was it what was happening what
was around you what was that moment for
for positive entrepreneur optimistic
people this actually might be a
challenge for me it was a challenge
because I don't want to think about the
bad past I don't think about what
happened to me I'm focused on what I'm
doing now and going forward not not rear
view mirror stuff what happened back
then doesn't matter except it does
because the thing that will fill you up
the most is helping people who are
currently going through the thing that
you struggled with the most knee
motivation
We Believe Nation hey it's Nina
Carmichael we made this video it's
because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrender yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best my husband Evan Carmichael and
his top 50 rules for Success enjoy
so whatever was the most painful moment
in your life from when you're born until
right now that you can remember not
physical pain psychological pain mental
pain the thing that made you feel
terrible what was that thing
your purpose is to help other people who
are feeling that right now
and so imagine who you are now and
imagine who you used to be whether
that's a year ago five years ago 10
years ago go back to whoever that person
was let's just say it's five years ago
great the person you are now can help
the person who you were five years ago
you may not have all the answers you're
still on your path you don't know
everything but you've grown you've
you've come out of the hole you're
better than you were five years ago
talk to the person you were five years
ago helping that person is your purpose
you've climbed up the staircase right
you have grown there's still a lot more
stairs to grow you don't want the
staircase to end that staircase is your
growth is your professional and personal
development for life you want to keep
climbing and every time you take a step
what you want to do is reach down and
help somebody else up but you can only
help people to the extent that you've
grown if you've taken eight steps on a
staircase that's all you can help people
up to get to step number eight
if you get to 20 you can help people
more so we want to keep growing keep
climbing those stairs and then keep
reaching back and pulling people up and
giving them a hand that's your purpose
for Life you'll you'll like serving
people and helping people and it's tied
to your core value your who your one
word we're not talking about it much in
this video but you'll just like helping
people because service is hardwired into
our brain helping people is hardwired to
your brain it has a similar impact on
your brain as food and sex it's
hardwired you'll like it you want to
help people you want to serve but who
you serve will be different it'll have a
different impact I love helping people
in general but if you're an entrepreneur
that's something extra special there's
so many great causes in the world
there's so many great causes why this
instead of this because you have an
emotional connection to it an emotional
attachment to it why because you went
through it
because you suffered through it and you
want to make sure that nobody else has
to suffer as much as you suffered your
purpose comes from your pain period
it'll fill you up for Life helping
entrepreneurs will fill me up for the
rest of my life it will never get old
when I'm tired when I have no energy
when I'm depleted I will still meet with
entrepreneurs because it fills me up
your purpose comes to your pain you have
to find it now let's talk about passion
so your passion is your how your passion
is the things that you're doing how
you're going to actually execute against
your why execute against your purpose
what are you doing it's great that you
believe an entrepreneur is amazing but
what are you going to do how are you
going to go about doing it so for me
it's making videos for me it's doing
speaking gigs for me it's writing books
for me it's helping people one-on-one
for me it's doing events right that's my
how
but that will evolve that will change
right I started doing this helping
entrepreneur thing when I was 22 years
old and that started just by doing
speaking and then it became my website
and I had a hundred thousand plus pages
of content and then I shut the thing
down overnight and I focused on YouTube
and it's been a 10-year plus Journey on
YouTube and and maybe in 10 years that's
gone and I'm doing something totally
different I don't know the how will
change a lot
what you get passionate about or tamel's
point about energy what you get energy
about will change with time but it has
to be connected to your purpose
just because it gives you energy it's
not going to fill you up it's got to be
connected to a deeper source which is
your purpose the difference between
outstanding and average is what you do
when it gets hard people with an average
mindset only do things when it's easy
because it's easy anyone can do it but
life is coming for you setbacks they're
coming for you and that's what separates
the average from the outstanding your
goals they don't count until it's hard
so I had a new guy on my team who's
writing to me to say Evan super
important this is urgent I need help
with my schedule I'm just not seeing
consistent I'm not staying on my goals I
know what I want to get done for you but
also for my life and and it's not unless
it's some deadline or you're on me it's
not happening I'm not consistent on it
how do how do I get going how do I stay
consistent
and so we work together through the
schedule and we created his calendar and
say what are your goals and put it in
your calendar and how do you want each
day to go and he plotted out his
Saturday to Sunday you know the whole
week and then I asked him okay now put
in your morning routine what do you want
to do every day right so we plotted that
into his calendar now he's got this
weekly schedule of what he's gonna do
every morning and then every day doing
different things and how he wants his
ideal life to go awesome
and then I told him what really mattered
like this is great your actions have to
your missions really important
but follow and throwing your calendar
doesn't count until it's hard
maybe maybe today is going to be easy
for you maybe tomorrow's easy for you
because we talked because you're
motivated because you're inspired it's
like yeah yeah I'm gonna go do it
awesome what happens when you don't
sleep well what happens when something
happens in your family what happens when
the website crashes what happens when
something happens what happens when
you've lost some motivation energy what
happens when you get some bad news what
happens what do you do this is where
most people crumble
this is where most people as soon as
this one little tiny thing that
interrupts them they're gone they fall
off their entire schedule and routine
your goals suddenly don't matter anymore
you don't think they're possible
your goals don't count until they're
hard that's what I told them I said
listen listen to me
this is a great plan
that life that you wrote that's a great
life what you wrote down on your
calendar that's a great life for you
that's what you want
imagine if you did that every day for
the next year how different would your
life look like one year from today if
you were consistent on staying like oh
yeah yeah amazing I mean great
doesn't count until it's hard none of
this matters until it's hard life is
coming for you get ready
and what I want him and I want you to
realize is that
you need to expect it
because you're working your calendar and
it's great and here we go we're getting
our getting our objectives and going for
our goals and then when something hits
Us in the face you're surprised by it
you're shocked and then you fall off
course don't be surprised expect it
expect the difficulty expect the road
bump expect somebody to punch you in the
face like expected it's coming
and this is your chance to be
outstanding because everybody else is
going to be average the reason why you
don't follow through on your vision is
because you don't trust it enough it
makes sense that it's going to happen
but it's not happening yet people aren't
saying yes there's no momentum there's
no money coming in and you start to
wonder who am I to have this big dream
so then there's this temptation to give
up and go do something else and not
follow through on your vision but you
know in the back your head you know you
know that eventually for someone it's
going to work out you need to stay on it
you need to follow through otherwise
someone else is going to make money off
of your idea they're gonna make it
happen without you so I look at what I'm
trying to do here with with this Channel
with my YouTube content with my my
mission my purpose I'm trying to solve
the world's biggest problem I want to
spread more belief right the world's
biggest problem is that people don't
believe in themselves enough I think
everybody is a genius everybody has
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
they're just not living it they're not
doing it they're not expressing it and
so they end up living a life that they
don't like knowing that they're capable
of more like this is the problem I am
trying to solve it's one that that I'm
never going to fully solve in my
lifetime and I wake up every day trying
to do it and it's easy to get up and
think well there's so many people trying
to do the same thing there's there's
Tony Robbins and there's all these other
people who am I to go off and do this
and I remind myself that I may not be
Tony Robbins I may not ever have as big
an impact I may not sell as many books
as Simon signic I mean I may never have
that big an impact
but I was able to help some people
yeah we've have two million subscribers
across the channels we have 300 million
views across the channels it's having an
impact it's helping people
I can get better I need to get better
but what I'm doing is already having an
impact in helping people so I need to
keep going and that's what I find really
helpful just reminding yourself that
that you matter that the work you do
matters even if it hit one person it
made a difference it matters and so you
have to follow through you need to be
your biggest critic as well as your
biggest fan people are usually their
biggest critics you point out all the
flaws you tell yourself all the reasons
why you suck I actually think that's a
good thing being your biggest critic
forces you to get better but it's only
healthy if it's paired with you also
being your biggest fan you think that
you suck but you also feel like you're
amazing like you're a gift to the world
like you're the best thing ever you suck
and you're amazing you're the worst and
you're the best both I think that's a
healthy balance you have to be your
biggest critic as well as your biggest
fan both at the same time also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there people don't push themselves to
the extreme
they just don't
it's because it's too hard it's too
crazy hard that you're not likely to do
it on your own and so I think when those
opportunities come learning to embrace
them learning to take them on learning
to say this is my chance to show myself
in the world what I am made of this is
my chance
but is it still your limit so let me
give you a couple examples this morning
I woke up and I didn't have a lot of
sleep I went to bed at three something
last night I woke up at 7 20 this
morning I turned off the alarm but still
woke up at 7 20. force a habit and I'm
not on a lot of sleep and I need to make
a bunch of videos for you guys and I
want to bring my best and I put pressure
on myself that every video needs to be
my best I want it to be better I want to
grow I don't want to just do the same
thing over and over and over again
but it's a challenge and so it's easy to
say oh I'm so tired I don't have energy
I I wish I slept more or an excuse after
excuse but no I'm gonna go do it and
here I am and I've made I don't know how
many videos are ready today I'm closing
in on finishing up and I still have
energy and I'm pumped for how it went
and in the story I'm telling myself is
I'm awesome like I had very little sleep
it's not how I want to be living every
day but when that happens what do you do
how do you stand up how do you show
yourself What You're Made Of
but even that is not the biggest extreme
you know like I feel like I'm capable of
way more
my tour
was the most that I'd ever pushed myself
not just mentally not just facing fears
but physically physically pushing myself
where I broke my neck in two spots I had
a concussion I've never had a concussion
before I was wild
don't wish anybody if you haven't
experienced it yet uh had three Staples
in my head I compressed my spine it was
brutal
and I had to cancel my event in Denver
where I was because it was that night
and then the next one was going to be in
Kansas City this is what I wore for for
60 days I wore these and I took them off
for 10 minutes a day
60 days right like this is what I made
it this is what I'm capable of I'm
complaining about having four hours
sleep I did I had my neck broken and
continued on my tour
across the U.S for 30 more days and
another 30 days here in Toronto
seeing entrepreneurs sitting in pain at
the front of the room with ice packs and
pillows and not quitting and going home
even though I was in massive pain like
this is who I am and I'm complaining
about not having sleep the night before
right like perspective the greatest
point on the tour for me was in Kansas
city was my next stop we refunded
everybody the money because I wasn't
going to be able to go for three hours
but I said hey we already booked this
hotel venue
you guys already booked your night off
why don't you just come out anyway just
come on out and I'll go for an hour and
take pictures and say hi and just show
some Kansas City love
and I showed up and we went for an hour
and a half and then my wife pulled me
off
because my lips are starting to get dry
because I wasn't being able to you know
answer questions at Clues I'd like
because I was still suffering from the
concussion you know the the neck pain is
one thing
that's just sitting still I can't do
anything about it but the concussion
you're not supposed to think you're not
supposed to have conversations it makes
the recovery worse
and so she's she was watching me like a
hawk the whole night she's watching me
and then she sees me start the Fate he's
like okay that's it I gotta take Evan
home quick pictures and we gotta go
I've never been pulled off a stage
before
never for like for sucking or definitely
for a physical issue never never it's
never happened
this was me at my physical limit
that was it I was done I had actually
nothing left like somebody had to come
and say you are done
[Music]
fast right
I mean it sucked but at the same time
it's like man this is it I actually I
got to the edge I got to the physical
limitation I can't go anymore I'm being
told I need to step down and there's
something so amazing that you feel about
yourself that you were able to go that
far now you don't want to do that every
day you want to take care of your health
of course of course of course don't
don't do stupid things
and at the same time the pride the
feeling of Awesomeness
that you hit that Mark I can't explain
so I started telling the people around
me my wife my agent the people on the
tour that were planning the 2020 tour
and it's not going to be as good
this will be great we're gonna hit 23
cities 90 days East Coast Texas Mexico
you know Montreal it's going to be fun
but it won't be as good because I'm not
going to break my neck
right I'm not gonna hit I'm not gonna
forcefully go break my neck just because
right that's that that's
stupid don't do that don't don't go do
that just because and so I'm not gonna
face the same challenge
and so the point is also have a great
time it'll still be amazing but what we
went through what I had to go through in
2019 this year is
yes foundational like
I'm gonna remember this forever this is
who I am this this this is who I am
not the guy who
thinks that four hours sleep and making
some videos is a big deal right it just
resets who you are and reminds you if
you step up to the challenge of what
you're capable of the people people who
are telling you that your idea won't
work are not the people whose life that
you want so why are you listening to
them your Uncle Joe your Aunt Susan the
rest of your family the people who you
grew up with from high school look at
their life look at their life right now
take away their words and what they're
telling you remove the emotion from it
look at their life do you want a life
like theirs because their advice will
lead to a life like theirs if not then
you probably should be doing the exact
opposite of what they're telling you to
do now I think there's two types of
people who will give you negative
feedback you got the haters and then you
got the people who are just ignorant and
there's a big difference between those
two so let's start with the haters the
haters I call the little man the haters
their entire role and their life is to
bring other people down maybe they took
their shock this is actually quite
frequent they took their shot they tried
they didn't work they failed and so now
nobody around them can be successful
they get their value they get their
self-love by this destroying other
people because it makes them feel better
about themselves it's like watching some
train wreck on reality TV show right
watching relationships and lives fall
apart because it makes you feel better
about your life you feel better about
your life when you see somebody else's
life be a total mess right those are the
haters now how do you deal with them it
starts by understanding that
if you believe like I believe that
humans are built to serve right people
are built to serve you want to do good
people are good right both of those
things humans are good and we're built
to serve then what would get somebody
who was good and built to serve to leave
a nasty negative comment or to tell you
that you suck or your deal is not going
to work out what would drive them to do
it
they really hate their life
right like empathy is the first step
just feeling bad for them not not
sympathy and and using that as a
negative against them not saying well
your life sucks I'm not gonna that
that's not gonna help anything it's
actual genuine empathy if the highlight
of somebody's day is coming to this
video and leaving a negative comment
it's okay I feel bad for that person
if that's the highlight of your day then
you must be in a really rough spot if
you're if you believe that people are
good and they're built to serve and so
what that does is remove the sting out
of the comment when somebody is Raging
on you
that that you suck and that your idea is
never going to work having empathy to
understand wow this person is likely in
a really tough spot
that removes the sting of the words and
allows you to then be more
practical less emotional to respond
emotionally and feel like oh my God
maybe they're right maybe they have a
point maybe I do suck say wait wait a
minute wait a minute this person they
hate their life why am I listening to
them right just like the wake-up call
out of the the head game that you're in
listen to their advice so those are the
haters remove the sting and allow you to
make a practical decision the second
part are the people who are ignorant
they're your friends your family the
people around you who they actually love
you right chances are your parents love
you your mom probably loves you right
most moms love their kids your parents
probably love you so why would they be
telling you not to go do something why
why would they be telling you advice
against what you want to hear
because they grew up in a different era
your parents are pilgrims your parents
don't understand a world that exists
your parents don't understand that you
can have a full-time business from this
it doesn't make sense when your parents
were your age they couldn't do the
things that you can do
so they want you to be successful the
people around you who love you want you
to be successful they have a different
definition of success
success to them looks different than it
does for you because they're from a
different era and that's okay again
starting point is empathy understand
that these words that are coming out of
their mouth is love they're trying to
express love they're concerned for you
they want you to win they just have a
different version of what winning looks
like burnout is real but I think most
burnout happy
people are not
actually love doing
about being busy and keeping your mind
occupied all day you can be busy and
hate your life and get burnt out if I
was an accountant I would hate my life
and burn out in a day because I don't
like being an accountant but doing this
thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go to then
there's no wonder why you feel like
you're burning out so I recently came
back from going to Tony Robbins event in
Dallas he invited me to sit in the front
row and uh super blessed and grateful to
have Tony support and I went there with
Alex friend of the channel who helps me
run trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning every
event saying hey I have some friends of
mine you might know them don't be
celebrities leave them alone don't talk
to them let them have their own
experience and it always makes me sad
when he says that because for me meeting
you guys meeting people who recognize me
and that's a group that I over index
because people who watch Tony videos you
know they're probably going to find my
content
I like it I like it more when people
come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport I set up a Meetup right I had an
hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet up let's do a
local Dallas Richardson Texas Meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy I love it
hanging out with believe Nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and I
then took an Uber to get to my to the
airport and the guy who drove the Uber
was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one hour meet up
because that hour was open and
and it fuels me but if it was something
that I hated just that half an hour just
15 minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much you
rarely regret the things that you do
it's what you don't do that you regret
the most it's all the missed
opportunities the times you wanted to
say yes but were afraid the moments that
you wanted to bet on yourself but you
were scared those moments that's what
you want to minimize because it's way
better to know and to fail than to never
know at all self-confidence comes from
doing difficult things from trying
failing getting back up and trying again
a different way your goals don't count
until they're hard you won't make
yourself proud unless it's hard and it's
time to start making yourself proud of
your effort so I'm in the process of
writing a new book and I sent the book
out to 30 of my friends and friends of
friends to get their feedback and I'm a
crazy deadline with the publisher you
got I got it I gotta here this is this
is the copy this is this is what I gave
out to 30 different people and
they gave me all the books back on the
same day and then what I had to do was
go through each copy and underline I
underline can you see kind of blurry I
underlined anytime they underlined I
underlined because I wanted to see what
they cared about as well as catching
typos and everything else and I looked
at that pile of books I had 30 books I
had to get through in one day I had to
basically read my own book 30 different
times make one Master Copy underline it
the whole day and and it stressed me out
I looked at that stack of books and said
I'm going to get through all this stuff
and I just started taking action I just
started doing it and here's the thing
halfway through I started getting
massive pain my neck was was really
hurting me my back was really hurting me
my neck mostly because I broke my neck
in March and I'm still healing and
recovering from it and I had to spend
the whole time
I had to spend the whole time like this
right I got the books here on the table
I'm flipping through it and I'm doing
this and it takes a toll the whole day
doing it like this so a couple hours in
I'm having massive neck pain
[Music]
it's the best right like I gotta get
through it this is the time it doesn't
count until it's hard I don't want to be
doing this every single day right if
that's every day you need to change your
life you need to change your habits but
in those rare moments when you get the
chance to push yourself you either
physically mentally uh or just courage
because you're afraid of doing something
that's your chance that's your chance to
show yourself What You're Made Of humans
are built to serve period serving others
is hardwired into our brain it triggers
the same area of your brain as food and
sex if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving either serving the
world on this big mission that you have
or serving the 25 closest people to you
if you're not happy it's because you're
not serving so one of the hacks should I
do in my life to get me to do the things
that I'm afraid of or don't want to do
is through service if I can connect any
of my actions like making videos I don't
necessarily like just sitting here
talking to a camera but I connected to
service that I'm making this video
people are going to watch it hopefully
they get inspired enough to take some
kind of action and it's meaningful to
their life or business that makes me
feel good that's Service as soon as I
can connect the action to service I am
all in and that's the way to hack me you
want something from me whether it's my
wife or my team or general public if it
makes me feel like this will serve other
people and it would have a big impact
then it's much easier for me to get a
yes it's easy for me to say I am in the
fastest path for you to get to success
you're after is to model success the
idea here is simple you find people who
have already done the thing that you
want to do learn from them understand
what they did to get there and then try
on their hat right see what worked for
them and apply it to your business this
is what worked for me this is what saved
my company Bill Gates saved my first
company even though I've never met him I
haven't yet we're gonna make it happen
hopefully hopefully hopefully soon
I was struggling I had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money and I quit on my business partner
and I woke up the next day and said I
need to find a way to make this happen
like I can't quit on this too soon
because I'm going to regret it if I
don't keep going and so I said who has
done this before who's done this and I
thought of Bill Gates it was the first
person that came to mind was Bill Gates
I looked at his story and how did he
build Microsoft well through
Partnerships and so I started making
Partnerships in my business I had
nothing else to lose I was already at
rock bottom right I didn't quit on my
partner I was hopeless so let's just
give this a shot and within I don't know
a couple months maybe even sooner I
landed my first partnership deal for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars and
at the time guys I was making 300 bucks
a month so that money meant the world to
me like that was that was bank and and
more important than that it it gave me
hope you know like this could happen
this this business could actually work
and it gave me a model to then go and do
it again and again and again and ever
since then whenever I don't know what to
do on model success I find someone who's
done it and I try to apply their
strategies and make it work for me but
this is the important thing not every
strategy is going to work the same way
for them as it did for you
so maybe waking up early is your ticket
maybe waking up later is going to be
your ticket it's people who've done both
which is the one that's gonna work for
you you won't know by sitting on the
couch and thinking about it the best
thing you can do is just go and try you
try on their hat right Bill Gates did
this Dan Lok does this Bruce Lee does
this awesome try it try it and see
people pre-judge so early your actions
have to map to your Ambitions in a
one-off situation you can always be
grateful for what happened when I broke
my neck in Colorado I'm grateful for the
opportunity I'm the opportunity to learn
to push myself to get better but did it
map to my ambitions right whenever
you're stuck in a one-off situation you
can yes always default to gratitude but
if you get the choice this is the
difference between living an intentional
versus a reactionary life if you're just
grateful for everything that happens to
you and see it as a journey yes and
you've learned yes great but is it the
journey that you want to be on it's a
journey that will get you to where you
want to go because if the person who
wants to hit the town ends up on the
farm
maybe he's not happy maybe that's not
his Ambitions now you might say that
actually served him that is something
that he should have gone down right
every road leads to somewhere but is it
the road that you want to go down do
your actions map to your Ambitions I
think it's really important the guy who
climbed the tree amaze
right his goal was to be there fastest
to take the shortest path that's the
path he should take and yes he was right
and the others were wrong he was right
for him because he wanted to take the
shortest path do your actions map to
your Ambitions you have goals look at
your calendar look at how you're
scheduling your time look at where
you're spending time what you're doing
it on will the actions that you're
taking lead you to accomplish the goals
that you're trying to go after
if yes amazing if not switch things up
I think too often people have hopes and
dreams and desires and Ambitions but
then their schedule doesn't match up you
say you want to do this but when I look
at your calendar it doesn't show me that
you're doing it if you want to have a
YouTube channel show me in your calendar
where you're making YouTube videos for
too many people it's never you're just
not doing it ever
so then it just becomes a hope a dream a
wish a someday
some day is not a day of the week right
you got to put it in your calendar make
sure your action is mapped to your
Ambitions nobody wakes up every day and
says this is gonna be the greatest day
ever not to unlock not Evan Carmichael
not Tony Robbins nobody you wake up and
you're tired and you have stuff in your
eyes and you have lines on your face
from the pillows the difference between
successful people is that they demand
Excellence from themselves to the habits
and routines that they do daily the
problem is that thinking that these
people are different that if you're not
waking up with tons of motivation ready
to take on the day that something is
wrong with you the only thing that's
wrong with you is you don't have the
habits that set you up for Success every
single day and today I want to change
that so I have a 5S morning routine that
I go through every single day that sets
me up for Success that demands
Excellence I'm gonna share with you guys
today the first s is sing the fastest
way to change your state is to put on
music the fastest way to go from feeling
lower energy tired bored into an energy
of I am ready to go is music
put on the song not that makes you feel
the current way that you're feeling this
is where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're gonna put on really mellow
slow music what does that do it keeps
you in the same state that you're in it
keeps you exactly where you are what you
want to do is put on the music for how
you want to feel and so I have a
playlist on my main Channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
I listen to these are the songs that I
listen to every day they may work for
you they may not work for you there's no
Perfect song for everybody this is a
perfect song for you and so build a
playlist of the songs that make you come
alive here's the criteria if this song
came on it would force you to start
moving if the song came on you find
yourself doing this if the song came on
you would get out of your chair and want
to move around doesn't mean you're gonna
dance like crazy doesn't mean you're
gonna start building out the lyrics that
may be you awesome but if you're a
little more introverted or don't like to
dance something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what I want
make a playlist and put that on is the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
setting the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day s number two is Sun I like
getting outside I think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the sun
outside but also signifying that you're
you're leaving your bedroom you're
leaving the condo the apartment the home
you're leaving what happened last night
and you're ready to go off and start the
day this is especially important if
you're working from home because it's
easy to have your you know office right
next to your bedroom or maybe your
office is your bedroom
and carry that bedroom energy that tired
I just woke up I want to stay in bed I
want to sleep energy into your work and
you won't do great things if that's the
energy you're carrying to your work so
having some kind of ritual that splits
up sleeping energy to I'm ready to go
energy makes a big difference and I find
the easiest way to do it is to get
outside and get some sun bonus points if
you're in a condo apartment to take the
stairs instead of the elevator s number
three is sore and this is the most
important thing for me if you only take
one of the five I think this is the most
important one to take what is the thing
that makes you soar every day what's the
thing that makes you feel alive bold
confident what is that and put it into
your morning routine at some point in
your life you felt bold you felt
Unstoppable you felt confident it's
happened to everybody the problem is you
don't feel that way consistently every
day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man I could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the I don't know if I can do it
I don't know who am I to go do this
crazy thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence plan it
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what I do is
I record a message on my phone to to
Instagram to my stories to I put it to
LinkedIn and Twitter right now I'm
putting it everywhere but I need to make
a message so I think of somebody that I
helped yesterday
I think of somebody who commented on a
video who I met in person who I coached
on my Instagram live somebody that I
helped yesterday and then I make a
message channeling that person I won't
say the person's name but I have them in
my head I need to remind myself that the
work that I do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that two to three
hundred thousand people watched my
videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right it's wild it's hard to
like what does it even mean I don't know
I'm just sitting here talking to a
camera in my office and two to three
hundred thousand people are watching my
videos it's crazy I need to think down
to the actual person I need to think
about an individual that this matters to
somebody that the work I do really means
something to them and then I need to
record a message and share that helps me
soar and I do it every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that I put up every day maybe it's
watching the expressive videos like this
that I put up every day and some people
every day this is part of the morning
routine is watching an espresso video
and I'm humbled to be a part of your
morning routine for other people it
might be meditating they might be
watching a video or might be reading a
book listen to a podcast I don't care
what the thing is but you have felt bold
Unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what led you to feeling
that way and then demanded of yourself
every day by putting it into your
morning routine the third s is sore it's
the most important one the fourth ask
for me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and I want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout I put that into my daily
routine because I want to bust a sweat
and I want to stay healthy into my 40s
which is coming up and then into my 50s
and Beyond
and then the last s for me is scare I
want to do something every day that
scares me what I'm doing right now is to
take a cold shower so after sweating I
need to have a shower they want to show
up to work all smelly and so hop in the
shower but right away start turning the
colder and colder and colder and colder
and colder and then right at the very
end I go all the way cold and I freeze
and even just sticking for right now
it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way right from the beginning I find
really helps me people are afraid to
tell the truth you're afraid to tell the
people around you the truth the truth
that could actually help them that could
serve them you're afraid to tell them
the truth because you're afraid that
they're going to judge you you're afraid
they're gonna reject you you're afraid
they're not going to take it well you're
afraid they're going to be sensitive but
you're actually doing everybody at this
service and you're gonna walk away from
the conversation cheating like I could
have helped them I could have been more
valuable to them I could have saved them
for making a really bad decision a
really big mistake all because you were
afraid to tell the truth whenever I'm
meeting somebody I go to an event I just
came back from an event in Dallas video
marketing World whenever I'm meeting
somebody that I want to learn from I
will start off saying hey man tell me
why I suck tell me why I suck if I'm
looking at my YouTube thumbnails or my
titles or me on camera or any part of
something that I want to improve and
work on tell me why I suck
now why why do that well it's not just
because I'm a glutton for punishment
right I don't want people just yelling
and raging at me it's because when you
do that when you lead with that when you
say tell me why I suck
it gives the other person the permission
to be honest with you
because they have advice that can help
you they have advice that might be able
to change your business or your life but
they're gonna hedge they're gonna play
it safe they're not going to tell you
what you need to hear because they're
afraid of offending you they're afraid
of hurting your feelings and so you open
up and you say tell me that I suck and
why
and then invariably what the answer is
is well you don't suck but you know you
could do this this and that
and they'll tell you what you need to
fix
or otherwise if you didn't lead with the
tell me why I suck they would hedge and
they wouldn't tell you everything that's
on their mind they wouldn't tell you the
thing that you need the most which is
their honest brutal opinion on what you
do now doesn't mean that you suck as a
human
you're amazing as a human it just means
you don't have the skill set you're not
good at this one thing that this person
is an expert at and can help you
and so the next time you're going to an
event or you're talking to somebody who
might be able to help you lead with it
lead to say I love I respect you I love
what you do I'm trying to work on this
tell me why I suck
and then watch the honesty come through
people don't show up for one of three
reasons number one is you're afraid
you're afraid of rejection you're afraid
of failure you're afraid of it not
working out and so you just don't show
up number two is you're not consistent
you show up some days but you don't show
up other days because you don't have the
routines and habits in place to make you
show up consistently every single day
and number three is you don't want to
you don't want to show up because you
don't actually enjoy the thing that
you're about to do you would rather
procrastinate on it because you don't
love it and showing up is more painful
than just sitting around so my goal
today with this video is to help you
bust through these so that you can show
up for life and have the impact that you
want to have so I think the fear of
showing up is actually a good thing it
means that you are doing something
different something outside your comfort
zone something that is that is not
normal that is new and that's good you
want to be pushing the envelope if there
was nothing that you are afraid to show
up to today tomorrow next week then
you're not growing you're not learning
you're not pushing against your boundary
using Comfort zones and so even today I
had to show up but and again it should
be every single day so today I was
procrastinating on sending out an email
to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel and more cross pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed for the people with a new idea
that I had so when the idea was first
suggested to me about doing this and
reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay it's gonna require an
ask I might get rejected it may not work
out and I had it scheduled for today
because today was my YouTube day and so
I look at the list today and like ah
maybe I should start with one person or
two people or just pick the easy people
and just the fact that I felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant I had to go and do five I
had to do a bigger number I had to go
after the harder people I had to do the
people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
gonna care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it
I have just to show myself because the
worst thing you can do is get to the
edge of the cliff and say you're gonna
jump and then not jump It's better not
to catch that you're nervous it's better
not to even come up with the idea to
just float around in ignorance ignorance
is bliss than to catch it and then play
small and so as soon as you catch it
I've trained myself I want you to do the
same thing as soon as you catch it train
yourself to do it even if it doesn't
work out just training yourself that you
don't back down when you are afraid the
problem isn't that you're not a genius
that you're not talented that you don't
have wisdom and ability
resourcefulness and that you're not
Michael Jordan that's not the problem
the problem is you're not focused you're
not doing the things that you need to do
I just came back from video marketing
World in Dallas and I was being asked
about where to spend your time Which
social media sites to spend time on and
I think this is a classic example of
where entrepreneurs fail is you're
trying to do everything and as a result
you suck everywhere and feel burnt out
tapped out and not building momentum if
you get to the end of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off but you look back what did I get
done if that's how you're ending a week
you worked hard and feel like what did I
get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
I quoted Andrew Carnegie at my event at
my speech my favorite quote from him is
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket everybody's saying
diversify diversify diversify have 18
different multiple streams of income
look at the people who are who are one
person show with 18 streams of income
they're making no money
you're making ten dollars a month from
this and 25 a month from that and 18
cents from this you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like I do I've got 24
people on my team okay great now it
might be time to diversify but as a solo
person you can't do everything yourself
and you are a genius you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something and
that's where you need to find and that's
when you need to spend as much time as
possible on until you're making money
you can invest back into your business
and continue to grow this is why it's so
important that you love what you do it's
why it's the number one rule for Success
that comes up over and over and over and
over again is people love what they do
the people who are winning at the
highest level they love what they do
that allows them to be relentless
because you can talk about being
relentless and giving it all you've got
and going all in and grinding and giving
110 percent
but if you don't love it you're gonna
quit it may not be after a day it may
not be after a month may not be after a
year but you're gonna quit when it gets
too hard and you don't love it you will
quit this is why so many entrepreneurs
fail because you're just chasing an
opportunity you're just looking at the
fastest way to make a buck in 2019 in
2020 in 2021 the fastest way to make
some money you're gonna give up
unless you love it now money is
important It's gotta be in your top five
but it's not number one
it can't be number one if money's Your
Number One You're Gonna fail you just
won't put in the work the people who win
have something that they put above money
and that's what allows them to wake up
and be relentless and put in the work
you're looking at a guy here who sucked
at making videos you can go back to my
channel you can watch the First videos I
was nervous I was shy I still am an
introvert but it's through practice
through being relentless I've had my
channel for 10 years I've made five or
six thousand videos across my four more
than four now nine or so channels five
or six thousand videos that's crazy
right that's crazy who does that you
have to love it it doesn't feel like
work making these videos is fun for me
still 10 years later is still fun for me
I'm excited the second that it gets to
be oh I gotta make videos that's it I'm
out because the people who love doing it
will crush me I was looking at my
YouTube thumbnail uh examples I'm doing
a YouTube course right now where I'm
teaching people how to have success on
YouTube how to get your first million
subscribers get where is it get get get
there that gold button get one of those
for you write your thought leader you're
an expert I want you to get a million
subscribers that's that's the course
that I'm launching right now so I'm
looking at my thumbnail experiments
I have a 130 thumbnail experiments
happening right now on my channel I'm
testing 130 different variations then I
want to complete it and what what we've
completed and gone through 1100
something completed thumbnail
experiments just on thumbnails just
testing my thumbnails we've done over
1100 different experiments that's crazy
right testing big changes like not
having text on a thumbnail and making it
purple and crazy colors to really little
tiny changes like what if we just tweak
this person's eyes what if we alter the
shade of orange just little tiny changes
that most of you probably never notice
why
I love it
I can't help it
I loved I wake up when I think about
this stuff and that's what I want for
you
that's what you need to be doing and it
can't be forced Jerry Seinfeld calls it
the torture that you can endure the
torture that you can endure most people
talk about passion and purpose which is
great
but it it's torture for other people I
think everyone is born an optimist and
then your environment sucks the soul out
of most people when you're a baby you
don't stress out about how you look what
you're wearing or how you're smelling
when you're a kid you don't hate your
life and complain about the world if
there's negativity in your head it was
put there by someone and if you want to
change it you need to change your
environment so I've had the good
pleasure of seeing one of my friends
Mark Drager a great friend of the
channel been involved with the channel
for a number of years become more
optimistic become more positive and he
was wondering could I even do it is it
possible he was a guy who was naturally
naturally pessimistic he had a lot of
stuff happen to him like we all have a
lot of situations a lot of circumstances
that made him see the the negative of
what's Happening of be pessimistic of
not being the typical
optimistic everything's gonna work out
great entrepreneur and so what changed
over the past 12 months he's made a
significant investment in himself I've
been hanging around with him a lot more
we've co-hosted a podcast together he's
hanging around me my content garyvee's
content Tom Bill used content more he's
been to Tony Robbins seminar twice in
the past year brought his team with him
and he's slowly inching towards more
optimism more positivity that more
things are possible
because of the negative upbringing that
he had it takes a lot of unwiring it
takes a lot of shift in your focus it
takes a lot of with purpose with intent
changing your environment changing the
people you hang out with changing where
you the physical environment that you're
in
to make a change I went to Mark's office
and he's moving his office he's created
his own office he's put in a picture on
the wall of himself and then what he
wants to be as as positive inspiration
every day he's looking at what kind of
colors and what kind of furnishings and
and what kind of the core can I have in
my office to make me feel bold to make
me feel alive every single day
it's possible and I think that's the
starting point for a lot of people it's
possible to change your outlook it's
possible to become more optimistic that
negativity that was planted in your head
was put there by somebody else who hates
their life you were not born to wake up
and hate your life you're not born to
wake up and think that it's just
negativity all around the world you're
not born to wake up and be a pessimist
you're not it was put there by somebody
somebody else who hated their life and
we need to eject that person we need to
unwire the years or Decades of training
and in that void you replace it with the
thing that you want
if you want more optimism you you
surround yourself with the most
optimistic people you can find in person
on your team in video format in the
books you read in the clubs you're
hanging out with you first limit access
from the negative people
limit exposure you may not be able to
completely wipe them out like maybe
they're your parents but you can limit
exposure you can limit access either
with time or just topics that you're
covering and then inject more positivity
optimism to the people books resources
environment that you have around you you
need to make the big decisions in your
life with your heart and the small ones
with your head this is where so many
entrepreneurs fall down this is where so
many entrepreneurs make mistakes because
you see a trend you see an opportunity
you see something that makes sense it
just makes sense on paper it's so clear
this is going to happen but if it
doesn't energize you if you don't love
it if it's not in your heart to see me I
can't wait to go off and do that thing
you're never gonna win you're never
gonna win because you're going up
against people who love it you're going
up against people who love it who
breathe it who sleep it who dream about
it and for you it's just an opportunity
you're never going to win big look at
all your Heroes all your mentors people
you look up to the people who've done it
it's like I want to be like this person
in my field I want to be I want to do it
like she did it like she did it they
loved doing the thing they love doing
the thing doing it gives them energy
I look at what I do I'm here in Dallas
I'm about to speak at video marketing
World an annual Summit of some of the
top creators on YouTube to help share
give back help the community give
feedback Train on YouTube I love doing
this stuff
you guys not because it's a strategy not
because I need to make a video a day
because I love it this this is this is
the best I'm about to go into this
meeting to this conference and I'm going
to hang out with entrepreneurs all day
long from the time I get in there until
whatever time am I'm going to be hanging
out with entrepreneurs and helping them
with their business helping them with
their Channel because I love it
and if that sounds exhausting for you
amazing don't do it and if it sounds
energizing for you yes go and do it you
need to make the big decisions with your
heart and then your head's still
important it's like don't listen it's
not the message is not don't listen to
Logic the message is not don't look for
opportunities it's look for
opportunities within the thing that you
love
right if if I love making videos and I
love making content and I love helping
entrepreneurs but I went all in on
MySpace right now I'm gonna lose it's
not the right strategy right you need
both it's working hard plus working
smart it's following what you love doing
plus chasing opportunities but what
takes precedence what's the most
important thing your heart
the energy
if you are saying oh man Monday if
that's your mindset around Monday you're
doing the wrong thing you're in the
wrong career you're in the wrong
business you will never be the top
player in your industry it'll never
happen for you if that's your mindset
if you're itching to get back to it if
you can't wait to go to that meeting
can't wait to code can't wait to make
that piece of art can't wait to go and
make that video can't wait to sit down
and write lyrics for your next song if
that's the thing
then you're gonna be successful it's not
going to be easy it's still the long
road it's still a path you still have to
put in the grind and the effort and use
strategies to help you get there faster
but it has to start by doing things that
are energizing to you you're going to
spend so much time working guys you're
gonna spend so much time working as an
entrepreneur
why not do stuff that makes you come
alive why not do stuff that gives you
energy
and so I want you to get out of your
head I want you to stop making decisions
first from your head I want you to stop
making decisions only because it's going
to help you get some goal a short-term
thinking and you're never going to win
doing it big decisions with the heart
big decisions that give you energy look
at your calendar are you energized about
the week that's coming up
look at your account go load your
calendar right now load it on your
computer a little on your phone however
you learn your cat look at it look at
your calendar look at the week ahead are
you excited
are you excited about what you're about
to do if not you're doing the wrong
stuff
if you're only excited about 10 of your
calendar
you're only pouring your Genius your
Michael Jordan level Talent into 10 of
your time you're not gonna get to where
you want to go you need to flip it
even if it doesn't make practical sense
at the beginning
because all great things are made from
the heart all great things every great
business every great song every great
creation
started from here from a place of
passion from place of purpose from place
of energy
and I want to put some pressure on you
guys to go off and Chase it down because
so many entrepreneurs fail
and they lose a lot of money
it's not
an easy game but one of the biggest
reasons if not the number one reason is
because people picking in the street
people pick a business idea solely
because they're chasing an opportunity
down and they didn't love doing the work
there's a reason why in my videos I say
you have Michael Jordan level talent I
believe it it's true you you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
you are the best the absolute best at
something in the world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that their world
class has something or two they found
the thing that they could be world class
at but they don't have enough guts to
chase it down they don't believe in
themselves enough to chase them down
here's the thing
you need to First explore you need to
explore you gotta search you gotta say
yes you got to try things you don't know
that that Tim Hortons is your favorite
coffee cup until you've tried it right
you don't know that Sushi is your
favorite food until you've tried it so
she doesn't make sense
right this is how we think our logical
brain starts to analyze things and
because it doesn't make sense we don't
try it Sushi doesn't make sense you're
gonna take raw fish mix it with rice put
seaweed around it and then eat it that
sounds nasty right if you've never tried
it before it sounds nasty but best
a lot of the things that you might be
great at you are a judge and you are
dismissing because it doesn't make
logical sense you don't need to wrap
your head around it you need to wrap
your heart around it you have to feel it
you have to say yes and be willing to
try at least once if you don't know what
you're great at you have to say yes and
try things and you pay attention to the
feeling
the most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it I expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
to suck at the beginning you're gonna
suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again the difference between
you hating and loving your life is
perspective as Marcus Aurelia said the
impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
that negative situation that you're
facing right now will Define you either
you succumb to it and you hate your life
forever or you rise above it and it
becomes the greatest blessing of all
time the choice is yours and I'm going
to show you how to conquer it so you may
have noticed that I have this armband on
this really colorful armband what's a
story I have this on as a reminder to
stay in a beautiful state it's a
reminder to myself every day now
naturally I'm pretty optimistic and
happy and positive and I've trained and
worked on myself to be even more
optimistic and happy and positive and
consume things that make me even more
happy and optimistic and positive but
there's still some times that I feel
feel negative there's still some times
that I'm not proud of myself the classic
example for me is when I get interrupted
if I'm working on something and I'm in
the zone and I'm focused and I'm
building momentum and somebody
interrupts me I can be really short I
can be really rude I'm not going to say
anything offensive or
something that I would regret but I
could be I could be short and rude and I
want to I want to change that I don't
want anything to knock me out of my
beautiful state at least that's my
ambition that's my intention that's my
goal if I can get closer to it I'll be
pumped it's the perspective shift and so
part of my daily routine is I put this
on I don't I don't sleep with this on uh
at night I'll take it off and then part
of my morning routine is I'll put this
on and and it's a reminder as I put it
on that I want to stay in a beautiful
state today that I might get interrupted
but I want to be proud of how I deal
with it and then I look at it every day
it's hard not to right it's not just
some little tiny you know wristband it's
some it's it's Giant and it's colorful
and it stands out and it's a reminder
every day as I'm typing I see it though
like oh yeah yeah beautiful say let's go
and also something that when I'm talking
to people they'll ask me about it
because it's a conversation piece why am
I doing it right people are curious they
want to know and so every time somebody
asks me about it it's a chance to tell
the story again and in telling that
story even now as I'm telling this story
it reinforces for me this is why I have
it on this is why I'm doing what I'm
doing and so having some kind of trigger
that brings that up it really works for
me I think it could work for you as well
George Bernard Shaw famously said the
reasonable man adapts himself to the
world the unreasonable one persists in
trying to adapt the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
Unreasonable Man the entrepreneurs who
win are the unreasonable women and men
who are trying to make a difference
you're different you don't fit in stop
trying to instead make the world adapt
to you I want to tell you a story about
guanyu and his guandau
let me get my prop so this is a heavy
statue with made bronze
stops from this
we good can we see okay good this is
guanyu guanyu is a legendary uh Chinese
General god of war and he was a huge man
in Chinese history he was huge by by
stature giant he was bigger than
everybody else that he was fighting
against so when he was getting started
in fighting when people gave him a
regular sword or staff or spear it was
so light for him it was too easy for him
because he was such a giant Beast of a
man and so instead of just taking the
tools that everybody else was using he
made his own weapon called the Guan Dao
it's this it's this crazy thing right
here it's this crazy you know staff with
a giant blade on the end of it gwanda
nobody else could lift this thing
because it was so heavy but he had it
crafted for him because he could lift it
and it made him even more powerful than
everybody else because he had this giant
weapon that he was using in all of his
fights that's what I think entrepreneurs
need to do that's what you need to do
you are a genius you are Michael Jordan
that's something you are go on you at
something the greatest fighter in China
at the time right that's you at
something
and for you to win
you need to have your own guandal you
need to craft your weapon craft your
business craft your habits craft your
activities craft the people around you
so that you can leverage what you're
naturally great at I make videos right I
love having my own message I love DJing
content
it's what I love doing
I can make four videos a day across my
channels because I have a team of people
who help create all of this stuff if it
was just me doing everything I would not
be making the content that I am
I built the business around me what I'm
great at what I love doing what I want
to continue to Excel and improve at you
need to find the same thing for you you
are a guanyu you are a Michael Jordan
it's time to embrace that and then
create something that hasn't been
created before that's what entrepreneurs
are doing create your guandal to let you
do what you're so good at at an even
higher level if you are the most
ambitious person that you know you are
going to play small for life look around
at your friends your family the people
that you hang out with what do they want
out of life if you're the one always
pushing them and no one's pushing you
guess what happens you don't get the
push that you need and you stay in
mediocrity being the best in a group of
unambitious people so I just came back
from an event in Florida that I was
doing a keynote at and at the end I
challenged an entrepreneur who showed up
to make some changes on this YouTube
channel we met over dinner I helped him
with his YouTube channel it was him and
his business partner sitting there and I
said by tomorrow here's what I want you
to do I want you to go in and make sure
you have these things updated and he
said yes I'll do it I said it's
important to do it by tomorrow because
I'm still here I'm still here in the
morning if you need anything you can ask
me face to face while I'm still here
before I fly home to Toronto yes I'll do
it next morning comes around
we show up in a meeting I gotta meet up
happening we got I don't know 30 people
who showed up to to meet with me and I
see him out of the corner of my eye
sitting at the back of the room and I
say hey did you do the thing that I told
you to do
they said no I didn't do it
I said why what happened
said well we we were doing lots of other
stuff it's been a full day you know we
had this entire day of of speaking and
meeting people and then so much
information went home we were doing all
this kind of work
okay great but what about the promise
that you made to me to do it and then
his business partner chimes in and said
you know it's actually my fault I told
him Evan's probably not gonna notice
he's not gonna remember don't worry
about it we'll take care of it when we
all fly back home
and so I told him
don't let your business partners low
standards prevent you from moving
forward on the things that you said you
were gonna do
staying committed to the thing that you
say you're gonna do your word to
yourself is the whole game forget about
what you just say to other people what
do you do for yourself because we're
often looking for no's we're often
looking for somebody else to give us a
break right he's been working hard and
and he is and I know him and I know his
business partner and these guys are not
Slackers they're not Slackers and and I
was poking a little bit at his business
partner saying his low expectations his
low standards but in this situation it
was true
like entrepreneur that I was speaking to
said he was gonna do this thing by
tomorrow morning before he came and went
to my event he would do it
and his business partner says he's not
going to remember don't worry we've
worked too hard already let it go we'll
do it when we get home and they would do
it when they got home I know they would
he's looking for the reason not to do it
when you say you want to hit the gym
when you say you want to hit these
business goals when you say you want to
have this outcome and be proud of the
effort that you put in every day when
you say that you're going to do
something
there will be moments where you want to
let yourself off the hook where you say
I work so hard I'm so tired or I deserve
a break right this is the language you
use to yourself and so when that happens
you're looking for affirmations from the
people around you and if you are the
most ambitious person in your friend
group if you are the most ambitious
person what's gonna happen they're gonna
say you already work so hard anyway what
are you talking about yes of course give
yourself the break and it's the exact
answer that you're looking for because
you want to give yourself a break
now if you're proud of your effort maybe
you should take a break but it's not
because somebody with lower standards
gave you the pass it's because you're
proud of the effort that you put in and
so this is where it gets really
dangerous when you are the most
successful the most ambitious person
from the people around you
they're always going to give you a
reason to play smaller
you can't accept it you have to push
through you need to change your
environment the free leads you to the
paid if you have no momentum no traction
no clients then start for free prove
your worth and build momentum give them
something they can't wait to have again
and pay for this time the goal isn't to
do free forever but the free gives you
the thing that you're missing the most
which is momentum in your business so
I'm pre-launching my book right now
built to serve and people who buy the
book and pre-order also get access to my
private Facebook group where I help
people one-on-one every week and so the
guy that I had on last week is a coach
he's a health coach he wants to help
people make transformations to their
health because he made a radical shift
in his health as well and I said great
well how are you doing right now well I
have a couple clients but I'm still
working at a restaurant I want to be
able to leave that so I can focus on
this full-time awesome if you're a coach
what I need to see you is coaching I
need to see you coaching people what I'd
love to see now is an Instagram live
regular show and what do you do on your
Instagram live you bring on people who
need help being coached through a health
transformation because it's one thing to
say I'm a coach and I help people get
these results it's another though to
actually see people change to have you
go live with them one-on-one and help
them bust through their limiting beliefs
and their mindset and the issues that
they're dealing with and then they come
out on the other side by the end of the
call feeling hope feeling invigorated
feeling inspired because people will
watch that and say man
I want a result like that they see
themselves in the client that you're
helping and they then want it for
themselves now you get two versions one
will be free people
one would be like can you do me I I'll
take it for free
which is great don't say no don't get
discouraged don't get upset you want the
free because the free gives you the
content and so if they're willing to
come on and do live on Instagram with
you for free then you do it
and there'll be other people who say hey
I love what you're doing I need a
radical transformation in my health as
well but I don't want to be on Instagram
I don't want to make it public can I can
I hire you privately
Bingo right that's what we're looking
for that's when you start getting paid
the free leech to the paid one of my
favorite quotes of all time is whether
you think you can or you think you can't
you're right it's usually attributed to
Henry Ford from all the videos that I've
made all of the successful people that I
profiled from industry Titans to monks
one of the things that they all have in
common is the ability to focus on the
things that they can do to improve their
situation there are a million reasons
why your idea will not work out and
eight while it will successful people
focus on the eight reasons why it will
succeed and unsuccessful people focus on
that million reasons why it won't so
it's time to decide which one are you
smart people come up with really smart
reasons why you can't do something and
it's true there are a million reasons
why you will not win a million reasons
but there are eight reasons why you will
and you have a choice this is an
important choice you have to decide are
you going to focus on the million
reasons why you are not going to win or
on the eight why you will so let's talk
about being an introvert I'm an
introvert I still am an introvert I own
my introvertedness that often doesn't
come across you may not believe me you
might see these videos and think
evidence so extroverted type A
personality I'm not
I I get nervous in big rooms I don't
like hanging out with strangers I never
talk to the people next to me on flights
or the train or anything I don't go up
and say hi and introduce myself I hate
all that stuff I hate small talks I I
have zero need to be around people if
it's just me and my wife I'm happy I
have zero need for contact to fill my my
social
equation whatever you want to call it
I'm introvert I still am but I I use it
as a positive where it used to be a
really strong negative I used to get
into a fight all the time with my agent
and he said the problem with you Evan is
you don't want to be famous it's like
you're right I don't I don't need to be
famous I don't need the spotlight I
don't want the spotlight
and it finally sunk in that in order for
me to get my message out there the more
known I am the more people hear the
message and so how does an introvert
become famous well we'll see join me on
my journey we're on we're in this
together we'll find out together
but the thing that gets me through all
of it is one going in on the strength
and and turning that introvertedness
into not an excuse but into something
that's empowering I think as introverts
we listen better
I just came back from an event in
Florida where somebody at the dinner
table was saying Evan it's really
surprising how well you listen
yeah because that's all that's all I do
I focus on the person I'm talking to I'm
introverted it's not about me talking
it's about you trying to get a result I
want to help you get a result
and so introverts are fantastic
listeners and so you actually want to
help people make a change you want to
help be a great salesperson you want to
help be a great speaker you have to know
your audience you got to know who you're
talking to you got to be a great
listener I think that counts from being
introverted
and the second thing is having the
passion and the purpose behind what
you're doing gives you the strength and
courage to do things that are scary
getting up on stage and speaking is
scary for me my biggest fear is is
letting people down my biggest fear is
I'm going to disappoint somebody and so
when I go on stage it's always a fear in
the back of my head is that I'm going to
disappoint these people that they're not
going to feel like they got their
money's worth when I did my tour earlier
this year that was my biggest fear is
every four days I'd be taking a new
stage in a new city and I would just let
people down and I got to face that fear
every day every four days why because
the purpose it means something and so
yes you might be introverted yes you
might have a whole bunch of reasons why
you can't win but the people who win
look at your Heroes look at you look at
the people who you love when you look up
to look at who you respect look at who
you want to be be like look at their
store look at where they came from
chances are they came from a worse spot
than what you currently have right now
the opportunities of resources the
connections they had was worse than what
you currently have at your disposal
right now the only difference between
them and most people is they focus on
the eight reasons why they could win and
most people focus on a million reasons
why they're gonna lose you're afraid of
experimenting because you tie yourself
forth to winning instead of trying if
you base your self-worth off how much
you win then you're only going to try
things that you have a good chance of
winning that thus you play small for
life but instead if you base yourself
forth on trying on the effort that
you're putting in you will fail on most
days but you'll end up accomplishing
more than you ever thought was possible
so every time I go to our YouTube event
I'm always being praised by my
thumbnails people always say Evan's got
the best thumbnails go look at his
thumbnails model his thumbnails use them
as an example for the best practice and
I I internally am always saying our
thumbnails suck we need to get better
sure we might be among the best but we
need to get better we could be way
better than we are right now
why have we become the best
because I'm experimenting constantly
most of my tests do not work I use a
tool called tubebuddy shout out
tubebuddy huge fan we've done over 1100
split tests on our thumbnails where we
want one thumbnail against another and
one against another and one against
another trying to beat our best and most
of the experiments don't work they just
don't work I recently ran an experiment
of on my main Channel putting my face on
the thumbnail with the Youtube white
border against Tony Robbins and it
tanked it was like 80 percent worse than
our current thumbnail and that's okay
people don't like my face next to Tony
Romans that is okay I'm fine with it I
expect to lose I expect everything I do
not to work but I'm willing to test it
to see I just recently came up with one
thumbnail design where I made the
background purple instead of black
purple instead of black and it actually
did better it did significantly better
and so now I'm testing it out on five
more thumbnails to see does the purple
one do better than the black one if that
works out maybe I rolled it out across
the entire Channel but it's very rare
that I find the win out of the 1100
experiments that we've done most of them
will not work will never work even from
the beginning I'm thinking this is
probably not going to work but I'm
willing to test that's okay even if the
most likely outcome is failure it's
worth the test to see you need to make
the big decisions in life with your
heart and the small ones with the head
big decisions with the heart small ones
with your head why because your head
only understands a world that currently
exists it's logical it's practical it
keeps you safe but your heart can create
something new that hasn't existed before
it's why the number one rule for success
is Follow Your Passion all progress
depends on what your heart tells you to
do and then you use your head to figure
out how to execute it so I just got back
from an event that I was keynoting in
Florida and I was meeting these two
entrepreneurs and helping them with
their YouTube channel and one of them is
a really logical head first guy and the
other one is a more heart-based
passionate guy and they were they're
asking me so that their Partners in the
same business and you're asking what's
more important logic or emotion logic or
emotion and there obviously the guy
who's logic based thinks logic is the
most important and the guy who's
emotion-based thinks emotion is most
important right you want to think that
what you're great at is the most
important thing and I told them it's
macro emotion micro logic macro emotion
micro logic you need to do both so as
I'm looking at their YouTube stats I'm
going deep into YouTube I'm telling them
all the data they need to know I'm
looking at the numbers and explaining
your audience retention sucks here we
need to fix it the percentage of
subscribers coming to your channel is
too low all of this stuff we're going
we're going deep into all their
analytics I can talk numbers for days I
love numbers I love making data driven
decisions but it's not the macro the
macro is the heart the macros why are
you on YouTube right why am I on YouTube
why am I making videos that's the macro
and then you use your head to figure out
the how the science of the thumbnails
and the audience retention and the
playlist and the titles and all of the
micro strategies that you can use on
YouTube to grow but it's macro motion
micro logic and so as I was explaining
it to him as I said it was listen it's
macro emotion he said but but I was
listening to you as you were explaining
things to me it was very logical
yes
the tactics were very logical but the
delivery so that you would understand it
and then go home and actually apply it
is emotion it's not logic it's emotion
because logic can be everywhere the
answers can be everywhere you know how
to lose weight you stop eating junk you
know how to get fit you'd start working
out you can find it but why are people
not doing it
because you haven't connected
emotionally the reason why you
understood what I was saying and you're
willing to take action is because of the
way that I delivered the information to
you because I had you control the mouse
and go through and do it yourself
because I was encouraging to you when
you needed it and I hit you in the face
when you needed it too not with my hand
with words
right it's macro emotion micro logic you
need both to win but just recognize the
situation you're getting into your big
decisions with the heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to do it
so it's common when you come with a new
idea for something you make a list of
pros and cons right and that's your
heart often talking against your head
where you have this giant list and you
say well these are all the reasons not
to do it but there's only one reason why
I want to do it and so if it's 10 con
and one pro what do you do if you just
look at numbers you go for the con but
maybe the one reason why is you just
love it
when you're heading your heart at
working together it's easy when you're
heading your harder opposite that's when
it slows momentum that's when nothing
happens because you want to do it but it
doesn't make sense to do it you really
love it you have to do it but it's no
There's no practical logical safe sense
to do it
you need to get them aligned your heart
needs to say listen to me brain we're
going now help me figure out how to get
there we're jumping now let's figure out
how to make our parachute on the way
down that's how it is big decision with
the heart small ones with the head the
secret to getting everything that you
want out of life is to think big and act
small think big have a huge Dream create
a vision for yourself that excites you
that you want to make happen and then
act small don't let the big dream be so
big that it becomes so scary and you
never start find the smallest possible
way to just get started think big act
small otherwise your dreams will stay
exactly that you don't do you because
you're afraid of negative judgment
you're afraid of what your family will
think you're afraid of what your friends
will think you're afraid of what total
strangers will think you'll sing in the
shower but you won't sing outside
walking down the street why it's not
because you're afraid of failing it's
because you're afraid of failing in
front of other people until you crush
that fear of judgment from other people
you will never accomplish the big goals
in your life and today I'm going to show
you how so last weekend I was in Dallas
I was doing a speech at video marketing
World which is a fantastic event put on
every year in Dallas where some of the
top video creators come to try to help
other people are trying to get started
in video marketing build their business
and I had a really important session at
the front
and I was nervous going into it because
I just made a big move on my YouTube
channel my main Channel I split into
eight or nine multiple different
channels so now instead of just running
my main Channel we got channels like
this which is dedicated to its own
channel now when I was thinking about
doing a move it was recommended to me
by Matt Guillen who's one of five people
who who I would really listen to for
YouTube advice there's five people in
the world who said Evan you suck on
YouTube here are the things that you
should do to get better right I'm at The
Cutting Edge there's five people who had
listened to one of them is Matt Guillen
and he told me to split up my channel
another one of the five is Jeremy vest
and he told me don't do the split up
I've known Jeremy for a number of years
he's helped me a lot I've helped him a
lot I really respect his opinion he said
do not split up the channels it's better
to keep them all on one channel and so
I'm faced with the Dilemma of which one
do I do and I decided that I'd rather no
one fail than not know that I would
rather do it because I know what my
channel looks like now having all the
videos on one channel I know what that
looks like I didn't know what having
multiple channels look like and so I'd
rather no one fail than not know but
here's the thing why do I tell this
story because when I'm in Dallas
the person who is putting on the event
was Jeremy vest the guy who told me not
to split up the channels the guy who
said this is a mistake you shouldn't do
it you should keep all the videos on one
channel and what did I end up doing I
did the opposite right I did what Matt
said and not Jeremy and so I knew this
question would come up when I was on
stage because everybody there knew that
I had split up my channels and was
wondering how it would work out and my
default response as I thought about it
was I don't want to go deep into the
story because Jeremy is here in the room
and this is his event he's not just
attending he's hosting it this is his
event I don't want to make him feel bad
I don't want to make it seem like he's
on a spot or that I wouldn't want to
listen to his advice because I love him
and respect him and I love hearing his
perspective
but the fact that I was afraid of it
meant that I had to do it that's
something I've treated myself to do that
I want you to train yourself to do as
well that the fact that you are afraid
of what somebody else is going to say or
think means you have to do it you have
to step into it you can't teach yourself
that when you think of something and
you're afraid that you play small it's
better not even to think about it's
better not to catch your insecurity when
you catch it you have to train yourself
to go off and do it
and then I default to thinking okay well
how can I do this in a way that is
respectful to Jeremy that is loving to
Jeremy that that I I can show people how
much I appreciate his feedback that I
don't make him look bad at his own event
how can I do that and then that question
asking leads you to better answers and
so it came up just like I thought it was
going to come up and I talked about it
and Jeremy was it offended and Jeremy
did not look bad and I accomplished my
objective
and I did it made myself feel proud
because I was nervous because I was
afraid and so that's what I want to
teach you that the next time that you're
afraid that the next time you're feeling
small the next time you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you that you
go and you take action that you do the
thing
because you cannot play small for life
if you are worried about what people
think of you you will never accomplish
the big goals in your business because
you have big goals you're an
entrepreneur you want to do amazing
things you have big Ambitions that will
never happen if you're afraid of what
one person is going to think of you
humans are built to serve you want to
help people it's hardwired into US
serving other people touches the same
part of our brain as eating food and
having sex you need it but how do you
serve what is your purpose how do you
find your passion I'm going to answer
that in this video so earlier this year
I went across 90 days 23 cities across
the US on a tour speaking tour and in my
head my plan was to talk about how to
overcome judgment how to take the two
percent difference and just start acting
on your ideas and I had this template
for what I wanted to talk about and as I
started getting more questions the
single thing that came up over and over
and over again from 23 different cities
across the entire country from
Pittsburgh to San Diego and back
was how do I find my purpose what's my
passion what am I supposed to be doing
and in every single City I had to walk
people through this process and because
it became so important I started to
write a book on it because I basically
went through interventions with people
where I had them stand up and and had
them go through a three-step process and
I'm going to walk you through in this
video in a minute and they got a result
and suddenly after years or Decades of
no Clarity they had Clarity on what they
should be doing and what their purpose
was what their passion was and what
their path forward was Step One is who
step two is why and step three is how so
let's start with step one it's your who
it's your most important core value
humans are built off of core values and
is one that's more important than all
the others if you had to decide what is
your single most important core value
what is it you may not know exactly but
you're gonna get pretty close just just
go down this thought exercise for now
what is one important core value that
you hold that if if people around you
were the opposite of it it would be
toxic to you it's important to figure
out because
when people don't know what their most
important core value is you get pulled
into a whole bunch of different
directions you get pulled to follow
somebody else's purpose somebody else's
Mission and settle for it but what
you're settling for is crumbs it's
crumbs of purpose because it's their
purpose that you're just kind of helping
instead of you actually living your
purpose makes a massive difference it
starts with what is your single most
important core value and you can look at
that by what are all the things that
have made you come alive in the past the
people you love the relationship that
worked out that the thing you learned
from your teachers the most why you love
those people so much is a Common Thread
and when you figure that out it allows
you to build a better life and business
going forward with intention around your
most important core value and bringing
people alongside your mission to support
you so you're working with the people
who are like-minded instead of having a
random assortment of people who might
have great skills with different values
and it doesn't work out step two is your
why this is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain
your purpose comes from your pain think
about the most painful moment you had
growing up in your past it doesn't have
to be from eight years old maybe it was
something that happened two years ago
but the most painful moment in your life
what was it well you felt not physical
pain but emotional pain that you felt
worthless as a human being when did you
feel the most worthless as a human being
that moment
helping other people is built into you
right humans are built to serve but
helping people who are exactly like that
will be the people that you love helping
for the rest of your life
because whether that was two years ago
five years ago 20 years ago let's just
say it was five years ago for this
example the person who you were five
years ago you've grown a lot since then
you may not be out of the woods you may
not have figured it all out you're still
on your journey you're still learning
and growing and you never want to stop
learning and growing but you're way
better than you used to be you're way
better than you were five years ago now
there's a lot of people who are exactly
who you used to be five years ago and
they're struggling and they need help
and they need guidance and they're
afraid and they don't know what to do
you can help them just like the version
of you right now could go back five
years and help the person who used to be
there are a lot of people who are what
you used to be they currently are what
you used to be
you can help them and helping them it's
not just a matter of you can
it'll fill you up it'll never get old
for the rest of your life your purpose
comes from your pain and in step three
is your how this is your passion so how
did you get out of it how did you solve
the problem again you might not be
totally out of the woods you're still
learning and growing amazing but you've
learned a lot since the person you were
five years ago how did you get out of it
what did you do
was it watching YouTube videos was it
meditation was it getting in shape
eating better food what was it what did
you do what did you do to save yourself
that was not a random occurrence that
was not something that can just work for
you that's a recipe that you can apply
to help other people as well the path
that you took to get out or at least get
a little bit better than where you used
to be is something that is teachable
that you can help other people with as
well and give them hope and give them
momentum and give them confidence and
again that will fill you up for the rest
of your life your fear of other people's
judgment is the single biggest Factor
holding back the success of your life
you want to serve others humans are
built to serve others you need it it's
your purpose but serving requires
someone else and as long as you're
worried about that person's judgment and
opinion of you you will stay still and
never act so you've got one foot on the
brake and one foot on the gas pushing
hard spinning your wheels and never
going anywhere knowing that you're
capable of a lot more but afraid to take
action I don't tell a lot of stories
about my parents they had a huge impact
on my life they're here on the wall
behind me I'm eight or nine years old
and that's them above me they're really
private people so I I keep the stories
that I share about them to a minimum but
one of my favorites are when I was in
school I was in art class and the
teacher told me to do a project and he
said paint a window and so I painted a
window and then I added a sailboat and I
added sunshine and I paint I had had
some curtains and I added a lot more to
the painting and I failed the assignment
because the teacher said I asked you to
paint a window and you did all this
other stuff and so my parents went into
school
later on and said hey uh what was the
assignment that you asked Evan to do and
said well paint the window I was like
well he clearly painted the window I
mean he did what you told him to do and
and they they stood up and became a
shield for me and I was blessed to have
an amazing parents you might have
amazing parents you might not it doesn't
matter either way but
wherever you learn and however you learn
you have to learn it that you need to go
off and express yourself you need to go
off and create the thing that you want
to create even if the rules tell you
that you can't do it even if your
teachers tell you that that's crazy even
if your parents tell you you'll never
make it and they want you to do
something safe and practical you have to
do it because otherwise you're teaching
yourself to play small and that
permeates for life you have ideas you're
a genius you've got Michael Jordan level
Talent on something you should be off
creating amazing things but you're
afraid because of other people's
judgment and as long as that is the
thing that is in the back of your head
that you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of somebody
else you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street because you're
afraid of what other people are going to
think about you and as long as that is
the reason why you're not taking action
then you lose for life you love
difficult things you do difficult things
are amazing difficult things are the
best difficult things are the only way
that you grow think about it what's the
opposite of difficult easy safe inside
your comfort zone boring the single
greatest thing that you can ever do for
your confidence is teach yourself that
when things get difficult you don't
shrink down you rise to the occasion so
in my keynote presentations I used to
always use slides as well I had
PowerPoint up and and I wouldn't read
the text off of the slides but I have a
picture and I tell a story about it and
it would always keep me focused on where
my presentation was going
and then I got offered to do a speaking
gig in Paris I was the keynote speech at
this big event for this software company
and I was gonna close the show for them
and I had this idea in my head that what
if I didn't do slides what if I spoke on
stage for I forget how long 45 minutes
to an hour closing Keynote
and I just had one slide and it was a
picture of a rabbit because I was
telling a story but trying to teach a
rabbit to climb a tree and it scared me
I thought it's difficult and because
that's what I thought that I had to do
it because in my head is well what if I
don't remember where I go what if I
forget the stories what if I lose track
of where I'm at and I'm sitting here on
stage the closing keynote been paid all
this money to come and I just suck
and because that was the reason that I
had to do it I had to do it and so I
said I'm just gonna have one slide
and when the tech team said hey what do
you want to show on screen here it is
it's just one slide yep no videos nope
no audio nope one slide that's it put
that up and I practice and I practice
and I practice and and because my
greatest fear in the world disappointing
people I probably over practice and have
my speech down and I went and crushed it
but even if I didn't it was the
willingness to try it's the willingness
to do difficult things that as soon as
you feel yourself playing potentially
small based off of something being
difficult that means it's go time that
means you have to do it because teaching
yourself that you think of something
that's big and scary and then you crouch
down and you shy away and you don't do
that that's that's an ongoing lesson
that you were teaching yourself that you
suck you're telling yourself if I went
and said hmm what about doing just one
slide in France right for my Paris
keynote what if it's just one slide and
I'm scared of it and I don't do it I'm
teaching myself that I suck that's what
you do anytime you approach something
big and you don't do it you're telling
yourself you're not capable you're
telling yourself that you suck and so
everybody else might let you up the hook
you may not even tell anybody else about
this crazy idea that you have but you
playing small is not acceptable when
something is difficult you have to
attack it head-on what do you say when
you see yourself in the mirror when it's
just you when you're all alone it's just
you you see yourself in the mirror what
do you say do you say great things or do
you beat yourself up most people they
might act confident and seem like they
have it all put together but secretly
they're fighting their own battles and
at home in private the comfort of their
own home they're their own worst enemies
the secret is to be your own biggest
critic as well as your biggest fan the
push you give yourself has to be from a
place of love and potential not lack and
despair so I recently posted on
Instagram a little cartoon of me passing
by a mirror and you see my reflection in
the mirror and the caption says I love
you and then I challenge people to say
hey what do you what do you say to
yourself when you look in the mirror and
giving them an 18-day challenge to say
every time you see a reflection of
yourself to say something positive
whether it's I love you or give yourself
a compliment something positive because
I think most people live in the land of
negativity all we see is all the
negative things that we're doing and all
the things that didn't work out and
things that could have been better and
that can actually be very healthy I
think you need to be your own biggest
critic I think you need to have higher
standards for yourself than what you're
currently doing but it only works being
your own biggest critic only works when
it's based off a foundation of love
when it's based off a foundation of I am
an amazing human being and I love myself
and I suck at all of these skills the
problem that most people have is you see
that you suck at a scale that you didn't
get the result that you're not good on
camera the first time you go out you
didn't get the result you didn't land
the sale you didn't make the deal you
didn't get the date you know whatever it
is you didn't get the result and then
you think that you suck as a human
because you don't have the skills it's
the opposite you're you're amazing as a
human it has to be from a foundation of
love that you love yourself and that you
suck at the skills and then you can beat
yourself up over how do I get better how
do I improve how do I acquire the skills
how do I move forward towards my goals
your environment has been perfectly
created to keep you exactly where you
are everything around you your friends
your family the media you consume all
keeps you exactly where you are if you
want to raise your standards and raise
the quality of your life it starts with
raising your environment so here's a
story I haven't told in a while when I
was building up my YouTube channel and I
closed my first multi-year deal with the
Big Brand it was with a CEO high-powered
CEO one of the largest companies in the
world especially in The Entrepreneur
Space and it was going to be me and him
on my channel every month answering
questions from you guys from the
audience we did a live stream every
month and it wasn't me interviewing him
or him interviewing me it was both of us
talking about a certain topic and then
taking questions and I remember driving
with my dad he was getting a new car and
we had this long drive out for whatever
reason the place that we wanted to buy
the car was super far away and so it
gave us this chance to talk in a car and
I just told him about this new deal that
I had signed I remember him asking me
Evan what gives you the confidence to
feel like you're on the same level as
this guy and he didn't mean it in a in a
negative way it was it was in a more
awestruck way it's like man look at
where you've come from because my family
is very humble like you have to be very
humble you have to appreciate what
you've got and so how am I now how do I
see myself on the same stage as his
high-powered CEOs being his equal
answering questions
and the question took me back and I
thought you know what he's right I mean
if this was Evan of five years prior I
would have felt not worthy I would have
felt like I couldn't do it I would have
felt like this is too big an opportunity
for me like I couldn't be the guy to do
it so what changed five years ago to
where I was at that point it was my
content it was my channel it was all the
videos that I'm I'm putting up because
in my head it was a big deal in that
this was the largest deal I had signed
for three years but more of that I'm
around Oprah every day and and then
paying you every day and Kanye West
every day and all these people every day
and so I feel like I'm with them
and and so this CEO deal wasn't that
huge a deal
because I had changed my environment
right I'd raised the stakes in my
environment and that raises your
standards and so I realized man this is
crazy how important my channel is to
myself at least to my own growth if it's
not to you at least to my own growth
because you often can't see it on a
daily basis I could not pinpoint the one
video I uploaded or the one day that I
felt this is it it's happened
but if I look back over a five-year
period a one-year period a six-month
period even a three month period think
about who you were three months ago if
you're invested in yourself by watching
these videos or reading books or
anything else if you're investing in
yourself even just look three months
back and think have I grown how much
have you grown in the past three months
you may not see it on a daily basis but
with months and then more months and
then more months and then years if you
keep on the path you'll see some
tremendous results may not even
recognize the person who you used to be
and that's why it's so important that
you raise your environment if you are
not focused on your goals you either
don't want them or you are afraid of
them you might just not want to do them
you might be in the wrong thing you
might have picked the wrong goals for
the wrong reasons or you're afraid of
your goals you're afraid of failing
you're afraid of it not working out and
what that means either way the answer is
action if you don't love it move on
immediately and if you're afraid of it
move into it immediately focused action
is always the answer so one of the
entrepreneurs that I've invested into
his name is Alex he helps me run Toronto
dance salsa which is the largest salsa
dance school in Canada maybe North
America and we're sitting down reviewing
his goals and reviewing his habits and
making sure that you know what he said
he was going to do matches to him
accomplishing his goals and there are a
couple things that were big things on
the list that he had to get done and he
was afraid of making mistake so for
example we're trying to create the
interior of the studio and make a wall
that speaks to the purpose of the
company speaks to the the mission the
vision what we're trying to accomplish
and we want to have something beautiful
that people want to take their pictures
on and he's so afraid of getting it
right he's so afraid of doing the wrong
thing that he does nothing and every
time he opens up the file to look at
what he wants to do and different ideas
he's afraid he's going to make a mistake
he's afraid he's going to invest time
energy dollars my money into something
and then when people show up saying huh
and it doesn't work out he's so afraid
to fail that he doesn't take action
which becomes the biggest failure of all
so here is our solution procrastination
Power Hour said every day PPH
put it into your calendar for one hour
this is your PPH time the thing that you
have been procrastinated on right the
thing that serves the business if if
you've been procrastinating on it and
you don't like it and it doesn't serve
the business great get rid of it that's
not what we're talking about it's the
things that you're afraid of the things
that you don't want to make a mistake on
that you're just pushing aside because
there's all those busy work that comes
in because yes we have to respond to
customers and yes we got to do all the
work that goes into the day-to-day of
running the company
but if you're so focused on just the
day-to-day and never focus on the things
that will actually help you grow the
bigger picture stuff then guess what
happens you never do the bigger picture
stuff especially if it's because you're
afraid then you have to take action so
we plan the daily procrastination Power
Hour that he puts into his calendar and
he looks at it when he gets there he
thinks what am I procrastinating the
most time and he's got this list and he
starts attacking it and having that in
his calendar is a thing that actually
started building momentum for those big
projects what would the boldest version
of you do think about your mission think
about your goals think about what you
are trying to accomplish you've got what
you're doing now but think about what
the boldest version of you if you summon
the boldest version of you into
existence right now what would he or she
tell you to do so when I did my tour
earlier this year was 90 days 23 cities
and at first I want to do it for free I
love doing free coffee shop meetups
every time I travel to a new city and I
told my agent Steve from New York hey
man this is my idea he said you need to
charge for the event you got to play
bigger you gotta you gotta do a bolder
version of you and it it's freaked me
out it scared me because I don't want to
disappoint people and the idea of
charging for something and then me
disappointing people and then hitting
that fear every four days because I got
up in a new city every three to four
days for 90 days was me being able to
conquer my fears and so Steve pushed me
and I have Steve's voice in my head it's
like you need to play bigger you got to
do something Bolder what's the next step
and so I'm looking at my next tour
coming up in 2020 around my book built
the serve and I'm trying to think how do
I make it even bigger how do I make it
even Bolder because what I've done has
been great and it's not trying to take
away from what I've done it's amazing
I'm proud of myself I'm grateful awesome
and I know I'm capable of more and I
know I need to do something at the next
level because if I want to go off and
accomplish my mission I need to because
at the rate I'm going right now I'm not
gonna hit a billion people I'm not gonna
solve the world's biggest problem
I'm not gonna have the impact and reach
that I know I can have unless I demand
more boldness bigger scale from myself
on a daily basis and so for me having
Steve's voice in my head having Elon
Musk voice in my head having Steve Jobs
and epiganini and my parents and Kanye
West and Howard Schultz constantly in my
head the content that I make is for
myself
it's selfish for myself and then I share
with you guys and thankfully you like it
so I could build a business around it
and how your team and and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you summon that
creature on a daily basis when you if
you wake up and you daily every day
consistently are bringing the boldest
version of you even for one year if you
woke up every day for one year and
summoned the boldest version of you your
life is gonna look dramatically
different one year from today stop
thinking that you should be Fearless if
you go through life Fearless that means
you are plain small and not doing
anything that is worth doing you should
be dreaming big you should be pushing
boundaries and in that push comes fear
instead of trying to be Fearless adopt a
mindset that you want to feel the fear
and do it anyway otherwise you will
never take on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission and you'll
always live below the potential that you
know you're capable of not asking for
help is selfish you might think that
trying to do everything yourself is
selfless that it's wrong to ask for help
and Noble to do everything yourself but
you love helping people you love helping
others remember that Joy you feel when
you help somebody and brought a smile to
their face knowing you made their week
by you not asking for help you're
cheating people of that opportunity to
bring a smile to their face stop being
selfish and start asking for help I came
up with this idea when I was at a video
game Cafe so here's what happened I was
I was on a call with one of my big
customers at the time and I was in Los
Angeles and we're doing a Google live
streaming to my YouTube channel lots of
people watching YouTube live I'm
interviewing him and then the internet
goes down like what happened the power
went out across all of Los Angeles the
power goes out and it and it's down I
got nothing the stream is still live but
I'm not there anymore I left my client
la live on the stream and he's he's not
sure what happens he just sees my camera
goes down and then he keeps going by
himself for another 15-20 minutes
waiting for me to come back and he's
he's embarrassed and it's awkward and he
doesn't know what he's doing because the
host
who has the audience there is now gone
and then eventually he just leaves
because he said well I don't know where
Evan is but
thank you guys for watching and it put
him in a really difficult situation I
felt terrible I went back to watching
the livestream after like oh my God I
can't believe that happened now it's out
of my control like you know the internet
goes down in Los Angeles what am I
supposed to do there's no power anywhere
so as soon as the power gets back up I
messaged my my client and say hey man
I'm really sorry about that let's
reschedule it let's do it again when I'm
back home in Toronto where I know I have
stable internet and and I want to do it
again for free no extra cost uh even
though we had almost finished the live
stream together we're gonna do a whole
other one for free just because I want
you to I want to make this right for you
great so we come back to Toronto it's
like the a week or two later and my
internet is pretty Rock Solid in my home
office I've never had an internet issue
really happen while I was doing a live
stream but I wanted to make extra sure
extra sure that this time nothing
happened because if something happened
the second time
just it would not be a good thing so I
asked my friend J rise and I said J rise
I need I need a place that has Rock
Solid internet that I'm gonna do this
live stream and nothing can go wrong
and he said I got a place as an internet
cafe that got that I go to I'll
introduce you to the owner I know him
and and you can do it there like thank
you so much so we go there I'm there an
hour early I'm setting up I'm talking to
the owner I'm testing the gear my
microphone the headset all of it the
camera testing all of it just to make
sure that everything is working smoothly
I'm nervous because the last time it
failed on us my client comes on we go
live for a half an hour an hour I don't
remember and it was smooth perfect no
issues crisp amazing internet blazing
fast speeds great time with the audience
and we delivered an awesome product
sigh of relief right I'm so pumped I go
talk to the owner and say dude thank you
man it was perfect no complaints no
problems thank you so much how much do I
owe you
and he said well
you are on the computer for about an
hour and a half and j-rod was on the
computer for about an hour and a half
but I'll just bundle it together so
I think what he told me was like five
bucks or seven bucks or ten bucks or
something like are you kidding me I
would have paid a thousand dollars I
would have paid a lot of money just to
make sure that this went smoothly
because it's the it's the relationship
with my client at the time right
I said okay well let me great here's
here's the seven dollars that you wanted
awesome let me buy let me buy some some
stuff from behind the counter let me buy
some snacks for my friend Jay Rice
jairo's was hungry he needed to eat so
like here here's 20 bucks 25 bucks let
me just buy out a whole bunch of your
snacks and give it to him he's like no
no you don't have to do that man don't
worry about it like no I want to do it
let me buy the snack no no don't worry
about it
the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought
that he was being selfless that hey
don't worry but you don't have to do it
that just just paying for the internet
was enough for him but he was actually
being selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he cheated me of the opportunity
of one saying thank you I wanted to pay
more I want to pay more you're cheating
me of the opportunity to do it and
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
help my friend J rise and give him some
food because he was hungry so we had to
go somewhere else you need to be willing
to bring other people in you need to be
willing to ask for help
yes you don't want to waste your time
yes you want to be respectful yes but
people love helping others we are built
to serve you want to help other people
that joy that you feel when you help
somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too if you quit on something too
soon that you still love you will regret
it for the rest of your life if you
don't love it anymore quit move on you
will never win doing work that you hate
but if you love it you love it and you
move on to something else you will look
back on this day and regret it for the
rest of your life that you did not see
it through most people spend their
entire life living with regrets don't
let that be you the hardest decision I
ever had to make in my life was being an
entrepreneur I struggled a lot with the
decision do I want to be an entrepreneur
and had this opportunity to make 300 a
month and earn 30 of a company versus
going to work at a job that I thought I
wanted a job that I've been preparing
myself for that this is what I wanted to
do was in my high school yearbook of
this is where I was going to be and here
it was earning six figures traveling
around the world doing the investment
banking I thought I wanted to do versus
making 300 a month and only only and
owning 30 of a company and the thing
that allowed me to push through and be
an entrepreneur was me saying I don't
want to live with regret
that I would rather no one fail than not
know
and I gave myself a year I said I'm
gonna give myself a year to do this I
could always go back and get another job
I may not be the same job it probably
wouldn't be the same job may not be as
much pay may not be traveling as much as
this job was off for me to travel but
this entrepreneurial thing this
opportunity that I had
I never knew if it would come back again
like I thought maybe this will never
happen to me again and so I decided to
go for it and we struggled and and it
was hard but I never ended up having to
go back and get another job
and so if you're at an inflection point
if you're thinking about which path
should I take a or b
lean in with your heart stop using your
head your head only understands the
world that currently exists lean in with
your heart
and ask yourself which decision will I
regret more if I don't do and then go
take that action
I became an entrepreneur because I
didn't want to regret not having at
least tried
and a great moment in my life came a
number of years later but one of the
people I went to University with came
back and said Evan
I went down that path I became the
investment banker and I hate my life how
do I become an entrepreneur
and I looked in his eyes and I saw the
desperation and the sadness and helped
him but also was so grateful that that
wasn't me because it could have been if
you want to figure out your purpose you
need to figure out what you stand for as
a human I wrote a whole book on it it's
here it's called your one word so but
finding your most important core value
who are you when you understand what
you're seeing the most important core
value is everything else becomes so much
easier so for me it's belief right
belief is my single most important core
value how does that help well with every
decision that I make it's seen through
the lens of belief every video content
that I make is about belief it has to be
every interaction I have every Workshop
every book every meeting all of it has
to be run through the believe framework
right the glasses I believe if I'm
hiring somebody onto my team skills
alone aren't enough it's great that you
can write copies do you believe in
entrepreneurs it's a big difference so
when you understand your core value
everything else becomes clearer and
you're less likely to follow what other
people want you to do everybody around
you they have a goal for you even if
it's well intentioned they have opinions
on what you should do with your life
everybody around you this is what you
should do with your life everybody has
an opinion you don't know which way to
go if you don't know which way to go
it's because you don't know what you
stand for because you're standing on
quicksand but when you understand your
one word you're who your most important
core value it's like you're standing on
a rock that nobody can push you from so
how do you figure that out quickly right
I mean this is 200 something Pages let's
boil it down super quick for you you
want to think about all the people that
you love your favorite teacher what you
loved about your parents think about
your favorite musician your favorite
band your favorite song your favorite
movie your favorite book all your
favorite things the thing that when you
are around consuming it reading it being
with them it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident Unstoppable right
we've all had those moments it's just
not consistent enough yet we're gonna
make it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list the
five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three keywords that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love Mr Jones it's not because he taught
you grade four math right there was
something else about Mr Jones that you
love why do I love Seabiscuit the movie
because it's about an oversized jockey
and an undersized horse and an owner
that has no money and all of these
things they all come together it's
believe right my parents taught me that
I'm Evan can surely Karma because I can
do anything that I believe that I can
right and so through all the things that
I love believe is the common thread what
is it for you you have to figure it out
you have to figure it out it doesn't
have to take you years of work just
write down all of the people and the
things that you love three keywords for
each like do this this is important just
do it today it'll make a huge difference
in your life it's worth it this is the
best 15 minutes you can spend in your
life do it pause the video and do it and
then just see what comes up consistently
what word comes up over and over and
over and over and over and over again
chances are that's your one word that's
your who then when you discover it you
have to start living that life
so you know if my one word is believed
then I gotta think okay who around me is
not belief what am I doing that is not
believe what projects am I working on
that are not believe and it gives you
Clarity and forces some tough decisions
and the more unhappy you are right now
in your life for business is because you
are out of alignment with your one word
if I was doing something that was
anti-belief if it even have made tons of
money I'm not going to be happy because
it's against who I am it's against my
core value same thing for you if you are
unhappy
because you're doing things that don't
align well with your core value and you
don't know what your core value is so
fix it most people never manifest their
ideas because you don't trust your ideas
that bold idea that came to you that
made sense to you in the moment the next
day feels too bold too crazy too insane
too not for someone like you I believe
that the decisions that come to you when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you and you have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way and talks you
down from doing the things that you
should be doing so right now I'm in the
process of looking for a creative
director for my business someone to look
at all my content suggest ways to make
it better to to be focused on The
Branding and opportunities for me and
this is a suggestion for Mark Drager a
friend of the channel a long time
personal friend of mine as well he
helped film my very first video he's the
reason why I did top 10 moves to success
long story with Mark and he said Evan
you need a creative director for your
business creative director or brand
manager or CEO somebody to be in charge
of all the creative decisions and
getting me out on the stages I need to
be out on so how do we make these videos
better that's that person's role and so
in my head
when he first said it I'm a little
afraid I'm scared like
how do I find this person I need to Vibe
well with them I don't I can't just
bring anybody into that role I'm a
pretty weird duck and so this has to be
a good you know long-term fit for me how
much is this person going to cost how do
I fit into my cost structure right now
with my business how are we going to
deal with conflicts it's all of the
negativity all of the things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on this is a
bold idea and I need to at least explore
and I need to try I need to play it out
maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
teaching yourself teaching myself that I
do both things I do scary things I do
difficult things and being scared is not
a good enough reason for not to take
action and so those ideas that come
through trust that they came to you for
a reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man I
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan you're
going to spend all your best energies
just stuck in planning mode instead of
actually going out and taking action
you're going to tell your friends about
it they're going to tell you it's a
stupid idea you're going to sleep on it
you're going to wake up and tell
yourself it's a stupid idea and then
what happens is no momentum the biggest
thing that is missing from your life
is momentum
Nina's happy Nina smiling she's next to
me filming that's all that's missing
you're a genius you have great ideas
great genius Amazing Ideas you're just
missing momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself why you
can't do it instead of going off and
proving to yourself that you can
self-love comes from doing difficult
things
it's from doing things you think are
beyond your comfort zone that you're not
capable of doing and just getting up and
trying to do it that's when you love
yourself when something is easy and you
win you actually don't feel that great
about yourself if you were to go and run
a race against three-year-olds and you
won great yeah you won you might even
post about it on Instagram but you don't
love yourself you don't feel good about
yourself because you played small
because it was easy because you were
expected to win because it's inside your
comfort zone when you play inside your
comfort zone always you don't love
yourself it comes from doing difficult
things that's how you build respect
that's how you build credibility it's
how you build self-love for you forget
about how other people respect and look
at you it's how you feel about yourself
that's the game and that comes from
doing difficult things so if you ran a
race against three-year-olds and you won
great who cares you don't feel great
about yourself because you were expected
to win but if you ran a race against
Usain Bolt and he ran backwards on one
leg he would still probably destroy you
but you should feel great about yourself
because you did the thing when it was
hard to do the thing
you might have lost to Usain Bolt but
you got in the race against him
that's how you build self-love when you
tie your self-respect when you tie your
self-worth when you tie yourself love to
the effort that you put in on a daily
basis that's when you start to win when
you tie yourself love to winning to
getting results you lose
when you tie your self-love to how many
likes you have on Instagram reviews or
subscribers on YouTube you lose it's
about the effort are you putting in the
effort every day because if you are
proud of your effort on a daily basis I
promise you you are going to crush it
but if you are only proud of yourself
when you win here's what's going to
happen you're only going to take on
small things you're going to play small
your entire life because you're only
going to take on projects that you have
a pretty high chance of winning at
because that's how you have love for
yourself
and that's a losing game because you're
capable of more you're capable of doing
a lot more stuff you keep a little
playing a bigger game you're capable of
having a bigger impact you have to it's
your duty
it's your duty to love yourself
when you love yourself you'll be able to
spread that more and help other people
and so how do you love yourself it comes
from doing difficult things it comes
from when your heart's beating like
crazy and you're scared and it's a big
project and you say I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try to do that scary thing I'm
going to try to record a video in public
where people may be watching you does it
mean your video has to be great chances
that was gonna suck
but you tried and you should feel great
about yourself saying I never have the
time is the single greatest excuse that
is preventing you from accomplishing
your goals you are not allowed to say it
anymore stop it stop believing your own
lies whatever story you're telling
yourself as to why you can't do it how
much time you don't have somebody else
who made it had it way worse than you
did they made it and had it way worse
than you did if they can make it you can
do the only difference is the story
you're telling yourself that you don't
have enough time to do it so I'm going
to give you a more fun example on this
one uh I want to get to being a better
League of Legends player okay I would
play League of Legends
I don't know once or twice a week
depending on what was happening in my
calendar I started sponsoring A League
of Legends player my first Esports
Venture this guy named Kyle menko and he
plays Teemo team was a character in the
game I play Teemo he's the best Teemo in
the world in any region around the world
he is the number one guy and I said Kyle
menko I want to sponsor you and part of
the deal is you're gonna coach me I want
you to coach me on how to get better I
want to get better I want to climb I was
in bronze which is the second worst
division in League of Legends I said
what was the best you've ever done said
silver which is the third worst division
in League of Legends and so he said okay
I can help you how often are you
practicing I said I don't know once or
twice a week it's like okay that's not
enough
I need you to play three games a day
three games a day
and a game takes 35 to 40 minutes
sometimes longer depending on how long
it takes to get into the game could be
45 minutes maybe even up to an hour I'm
thinking my head three games a day are
you nuts I don't have time to do this I
can't make that happen I got all these
other responsibilities
if it's important you gotta stop telling
yourself that you can't do it how do I
justify playing three games a day when I
have all these other stuff I need to do
I need to run a business I want to scale
I want to grow my YouTube channel I want
to grow my impact I need to write my
book I need to launch my YouTube course
I need to spend time with my wife and my
family I got lots of other things I need
to do I need to sleep you know all of it
how do I justify spending three games a
day to improve my Teemo
I don't have the time
your actions map to your Ambitions I'll
look at my calendar I made a way
I'm gonna do it I want to get better I
want to improve now I don't do it when
I'm traveling so I'm here in LA right
now so I haven't played my three games
since I've been away but when I'm in
Toronto
pretty much every day that I'm in
Toronto I'll get my three games in and
I've gotten better the results speak I
went from bronze to Silver and now I'm
climbing up through silver and I'm
hopefully the goal is to get the gold by
the end of the year so that was the
fourth worth fourth worst Division and
you're starting to get
once you get in the goal and you get a
little bit higher now you're starting to
get some kind of not reputation but
significance and just like you're
actually a semi-decent player right so
I'm I'm chasing down my League of
Legends goals because your personal
goals you may be watching and thinking
well what like why are you wasting your
time doing it's a personal goal to me
it might be a waste of time to you maybe
building a deck for your backyard is a
big waste of time for me maybe making
your own clothes or whatever other hobby
you have cooking or crafting is a big
waste of time for me right so don't
judge somebody else's personal goals
this is a personal goal of mine I want
to chase it down and I want to not tell
myself that I don't have the time right
as soon as you hear yourself say I don't
have the time you're not taking control
of your calendar you're not taking
control of your life of course you have
the time you choose not to prioritize it
that's that's the change in language you
need to make you're not allowed to say
I don't have the time
instead I choose not to prioritize it
because now you're in charge now you
have nobody to blame because when it's
somebody else's fault when you don't
have the time that's not your fault
somebody else's fault that's everybody
else who has demands on your time right
you can't do anything about it so let's
just stay here I never accomplish your
goals
choose not to prioritize it
once you take accountability once you
take responsibility to say I'm going to
take control of what I want to do in my
life that's when everything starts to
change you look at the people who've
made big money they've been they've been
chasing something that they love doing
because otherwise you won't put it in a
fork if you're just chasing an
opportunity you're probably not going to
make it if you don't love it enough
the people who love it will crush you
like if salsa dancing was the hot trend
for 2020 you could say great I'm going
to make tons of money salsa dancing
being a being an instructor and then
I'll do that for three years and then
retire and go travel the world and do
what I love you'll never make the money
salsa dancing because Alex is going to
destroy you
yeah because he loves it right because
you'll you'll be uh
a wannabe and you'll never put in enough
work to actually get great at the thing
like if you're if you're going to work
with somebody who's going to be in your
in your production
and they're just they just want to make
it as an actor because they think it's a
path to make tons of money because Brad
Pitt makes 40 million a movie or
whatever it is
but they don't actually care about being
a good actor
they're not going to get into your show
like you're going to spot that out and
say no I need people who I actually care
about the craft you don't have to be an
extrovert to sell you also don't have to
be a slime ball to sell either all you
need to sell is a vision that you
believe in and a passion to make it come
true and if you don't learn to
effectively sell that genius idea that
you have in here that can serve the
world will never come to fruition and
you'll never get the impact that you're
after so I'm here in LA and over the
past two days I've been on the podcast
for Jordan Belfort Wolf of Wall Street
and Jay Abraham who's the legendary
marketing Guru for Tony Robbins and
Damon John and a whole bunch of other
people and I'm on their podcast and I'm
telling them that they need to be on
YouTube that they need to get their
message out I want to see them more
heavily invested I want to see their
message reach the world and
five years ago
I've been a five years ago would have
been too afraid to humbled to worry that
I might not be perfect that I wouldn't
be able to persuade them to do the thing
and so I wouldn't have tried
and I still have a bit of that in me
when when Jordan Belfort asked me how
good are you like how good at YouTube
are you and the answer that I gave was
within the thought leadership world if
you you want to help entrepreneurs I'm
I'm top three five in the world
even as I said it feels weird saying it
because the the Canadian or Carmichael
kind of humbleness is pumping in but
it's also true
because when you're talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get in
understand you when I'm talking to
Jordan Belfort and trying to give him an
understand of what I do and why my
message is so important for him I'm
trying to serve him I'm trying to help
him I want him to win
so The credibility is important backs it
up and me not strongly believing in
myself means that he won't believe in me
either and one of my favorite messages
from Jordan and I told them this at the
beginning of the podcast interview was
sales
is about a transfer of certainty of all
the things I've learned from Jordan
Belfort that is the number one thing
that still Rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something again not for
nefarious reasons not to screw somebody
over not just to get their money you
want to persuade them I'm here try to
persuade Jordan trying to persuade Jay
trying to persuade lots of other people
to take their message and put it up on
YouTube to spread it to the world it's
for them right I got frustrated with
Jordan halfway through the interview and
he said why are you frustrated because
he's making it a joke and some and
having fun and he loves having fun on
the show and and it's a more
entertaining show he's way more funny
and entertaining than I am I told him
you're doing this for the audience
because people watch the show I'm doing
this for you like we're here at a
limited time and I want you to win I
want to get this out of my head into
here so you can go take action on it
right
so the ability to sell and persuade is
based off your ability to transfer
certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing when you fully believe in a thing
like this is right this is the thing
that has to happen in service in service
for your customer in service for your
audience you have to do this not for me
but because it's the best thing for you
when you fully believe it then you have
to go all in on it you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something but
instead of being world class at that
thing you settle for being just above
average at something that you should not
be doing Albert Einstein once said
everybody is a genius but if you judge a
fish by its ability to climb a tree it
will believe its whole life that it is
stupid that's most people's problems you
are a fish and you're trying to climb a
tree instead of going and being great at
swimming this is the exact problem that
I'm on a mission to solve so I recently
had a young entrepreneur come to one of
my Toronto q a meetups that are free
that I host every week and he said Evan
I have a problem I'm trying to decide
between what my parents want me to be
which is an architect and what I feel
feel a yearning towards which is being a
musician and I don't know what to do
I know how to decide I don't know how
I'm going to be a success as a musician
I don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and this is clearly defined
path for how to do it and he's afraid
I think that's so many people there's a
safe perfect path that has been designed
that people have done forever and ever
and ever and ever and ever or this is
new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people and you do what they want
you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it it's never been easier to
actually be yourself and build a
business and have success being uniquely
you right this was not open to your
parents and definitely not your
grandparents the ability to be an
entrepreneur on the side making money
using your phone is something that your
grandparents don't understand it's just
it's totally Wild
and so you are a unique individual right
you are I am we all are you have unique
interests personality traits belief
systems you're unique you need to do
something unique if you are unique you
need to do something unique if you're
stuck doing the same thing that somebody
else wants you to do you're never going
to be happy now there may be some
alignment you may not absolutely hate
the job that you're at but you know
you're capable of more you're Michael
Jordan
you are the Michael Jordan of something
you're a genius and absolute Bonafide
genius at something this is why I think
it's the world's greatest problem this
is why I do what I do every single day
in making this content videos for you
because I want to unlock people
hopefully more than one at a time but
even if it's just one person who watches
this video and gets unlocked I'm pumped
because I think if everybody is off
doing the thing that they are a genius
at man I want to live in that world hope
without action leads to pain and
suffering watching videos like this is
not enough it might give you hope but
hope that is not tied to action in you
doing something will mean you never
accomplish your goals the answer is
always action hope and then action and
when that doesn't work out more action
and when that doesn't work out more
so a couple years ago I was in New York
and I was meeting with my agents in one
of them
said what am I trying to do what's
what's my vision what's my mission what
I'm trying to accomplish and I said I
wanted to spread belief I wanted to
spread hope and he jumped all over me
about the Hope like you want to spread
hope Hope's not enough you can't just do
hope and and I remember walking away
he's like what's he talking I hope it's
so important if you don't have hope how
are you going to believe in yourself to
go chase something down without hope you
got nothing right without hope and
belief you got nothing
where I realized the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people hope things will happen it's not
having hope in something it's hoping
that it's going to happen and then they
sit on their bed and sit on their couch
sit at home and do nothing
that kind of hope that's not a strategy
hope and belief is your first step it's
your first entry point in you have hope
that things will happen but then you
gotta get up and do something right and
so
figuring out that message when I was
talking to my agent didn't come to you
right away in the moment because at the
same time as much as I'm filled with
hope and belief in humanity and what we
can all do I'm work right I'm taking
action I'm making three to four videos
every day we haven't had a day in the
past five years where video hasn't gone
up every single day I don't know what
that consecutive streak is but it's long
it's big
I'm working my face off every day in the
achievement of my mission but I also
love hope and belief it's why I have
this channel so I have my other channels
is I want I want to be around people
who've done a lot more I want to learn
from the great so I'm going to learn
from people who know more than me and
when I see that it gives me hope that
it's possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it I can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus actually executing and
doing it are two very different things
right the difference Gap is going to be
the action and so yes I want you to have
hope I think it's important but it's not
the only thing you got to make sure you
turn that hope and not just rely on a
strategy but you're doing the daily work
to chase down your dreams people aren't
lazy they just don't have dreams that
Inspire them they default to thinking
I'm a lazy person I don't have Ambitions
I don't know what I want to do in life
I'm just I'm just a loser no you just
don't have a dream that makes you want
to go off and do something and until you
figure that out you're going to be in
this constant cycle of feeling like a
loser it's one of the most common
questions that I get asked on my Ig
streams I go live every single day on
Instagram at least right now while I'm
on my tour and every single day I get
asked some variation of Evan I'm lazy
how do I get out of it Evan I'm
procrastinating how do I get out of it
one you don't call yourself a lazy
person there's no such thing as a lazy
person if you are procrastinating or
you're being lazy right you are being
lazy doesn't mean that you are a lazy
person there's two reasons why you're
doing it there's two reasons why you are
being lazy one
you don't have a dream that's big enough
you don't have something that inspires
you you don't want to get out of bed in
the morning if I was an accountant I
would be a really lazy accountant I
would hate my life not to knock
accountants it's just not for me if I
was a video editor I would be I would be
lazy I would hate my life I don't want
to be a video editor I don't want to be
an accountant actually there's most
things in the world that I don't want to
be and if you force me to do that I
would be lazy that's 95 of America I
think 95 of America wakes up and drive
to the job that they hate and then
they're lazy there
but they have dreams they have Ambitions
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you just have to find it and
so if you don't know what that thing is
then it's your duty to go off and
explore you test you try you see
you say yes to a lot of stuff like this
is the most important thing that you
need to figure out in your life if you
don't know what your dream is you have
to go off and try things
just like you won't get married until
you go on dates you won't get married to
an idea until you go on dates until you
try it until you say yes
and the acid test is did I like it do I
want to go back does this fill me up did
I enjoy the process of it can I see
myself doing this and having fun because
when you're having fun doing the work
that's when it will fill you up
that's when you won't be lazy and there
has been times in all your lives where
you felt that where you felt the joy the
energy the ambition the drive and so you
need to capture that and say yes and
find what it is that your big dream is
what is the most constructive criticism
you've ever received
seriously this that's a great question
no I had a great answer good Nation
anyway you tell me afterwards
how often do you take stock of your life
and evaluate the direction you're going
when you do okay next question I don't
like this one too
because it's too long right
now it was not if you can't answer the
question in 10 words she's out okay
we're someone you never want to travel
to and why
well I didn't even hear what you said
where is somewhere you'd never want to
travel to and why I went on to
drink it can be even like something
small like a sewer
[Laughter]
to be a country would you want to travel
to a sewer no okay we're taking
something like
I don't know what else how about a
slaughterhouse no what but where would
there be a slaughterhouse I don't know
General like you could pick you don't
have to pick like
China or something you think you could
pick us no I'm saying you don't have to
pick something you pick you have to be a
city or a country it could be something
anywhere it does it's thrilled my
I don't like to go oh there you go like
a horror Horror amusement park or
something yeah yeah okay that's a good
one that's a good good answer good
answer good answer mean a good answer
good answer
I would say space why well don't you
want to go I would like to go to space I
have no interest in space what if I say
hey everyone I go to space and I want
you to come by wow
you want to go to space yeah why not
it's cool
I mean you get to control you get to
control what like you're in the space
you know you move you could you know
it makes no sense you use the control
you get to move what
I don't like swimming
the fastest way to learn anything is to
model someone who has done it before you
you don't need to have all the answers
yourself you don't need to have Decades
of experience to win if you want to
shortcut your path and stop wasting time
you need to learn to model success so I
recently came back from speaking in
Phoenix I was at an event with Brendan
burchard and the graziosi and Eric
Thomas and a bunch of amazing speakers
and I have a lot of experience in
speaking I've been listed by Forbes and
ink magazine as one of the greatest
speakers in the world super humbling
award but I still want to get better I
still want to learn I still want to
improve and so before getting on stage I
was talking to Brendan burchard
backstage and he said hey I'm going to
watch your speech I'm going to finish my
interview here and I want to make sure
that I watch your speech and so I get on
stage and it's tons of fun I come back
out and Brendan is running down the
aisle and he's got his hands up and he's
super excited and he said that was
amazing and he's telling me about how
great the the speech was and how much I
helped his audience and thanking me I
said amazing thank you so much I
appreciate you let me ask you how do I
make it better you've done a lot of
these you've done more than I have
you're filling out you know huge rooms
full of people how can I get better I
want to model success I want to learn
from somebody who's done more than me
and chances are something Great's gonna
come back right like tell me I suck
Brandon tell me I suck how do I improve
and he gave me a bunch of great feedback
you said one I need to use the stage
more so I was walking
kind of like this I was walking around
like this and at a slow pace because I
think as I'm going but he said no you
need to you need to walk faster you need
to walk faster like this and always face
in the audience and there's this giant
stage that I'm speaking at and he said
you got to make sure you hit both sides
of the stage at least four times if
you're speaking for an hour you gotta
hit both sides of the stage at least
four times because Evan what you did
really well was you you kept the
people's Focus who are really in front
of you in this circle but the people who
are out there they didn't connect with
you as much
great awesome feedback I gotta take that
got to take that home and improve he
also said to to be bigger and more
animated and this also makes sense for
My Salsa background when you're doing
performance on stage you need to make
everything big because the people who
are up front can see you but the people
who are at the back they can't see the
Expressions they can't see the movement
so it's got to be bigger than you would
normally do it and so even though I knew
that lesson from a different set of
experiences and salsa dancing
I hadn't applied it yet to my speaking
and so it was great it was great
learning experience and if I didn't ask
friend then hey what can you teach me
what how could I do better the worst
case scenario is he says there's nothing
it was perfect great I want to know how
it can improve though right and he gave
me two pieces of advice that now I could
take into my next speaking gig to make
it even better right that's the idea of
modeling success you find people who've
done it before who are better than you
at least one certain thing and ask them
how did they do it and ask them to
critique you and break you down because
through that you will shortcut your path
to get in there faster because you made
it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there you have these moments that are
bold that are courageous that make you
feel Unstoppable and you can do anything
and then you fall back down because the
environment is the thing that's keeping
you small it takes